Four,
three,
two,
boom.
And we're live.
How are you brother?
I'm great man.
Living in here,
man.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I mean I've been wanting to have you on for a long time,
man.
I've been following your career forever and I've been a big fan forever,
so it's nice to be able to
down with.
Yeah,
I know,
man.
This is awesome.
This is a,
I've been a big fan of the,
of yours obviously,
and the podcast for a long time.
So to be in here,
get the tour,
check out your awesome man warehouse.
I think a dream.
This is an elaborate plot to convince me to get you to join the UFC.
That's all it says right away.
Right away.
We want to go straight to it.
Okay,
well I just,
I mean all of this could be yours.
I appreciate Rory Macdonald going over there.
I know he did what he had to do,
but even that one bums me out.
I wanted a,
I want to see you fight the best guys in the world.
And I think right now over in Beltour you have very good competition,
but I don't think you have the best guys and I think you're one of the best
guys.
I think a,
I think I wake up every morning and think I'm the best guy in the world to,
that's the way we want to be the best guy in the world.
That's the way I've been thinking for a while.
And then not always in my car
here.
I mean I've had some losses where I've,
you know,
had temporary lapses of confidence and whatnot,
whether it be my training or my abilities and myself or my thoughts and my
abilities myself.
But I mean,
where I'm at right now firing on all cylinders,
I feel like
everything's worked.
So do you feel like those moments where you haven't been at your best,
where you've had lapses and then you felt those dark moments,
do those motivate you to never let that happen again?
Yeah,
I mean I think I actually went through for those.
Yeah.
People that don't know.
I went through three losses in a row.
I mean,
that's,
that's rough.
I mean,
the first lost Eddie Alvarez was a tough split decision.
A lot of people thought I won.
Um,
so you kind of get this,
you know,
oh,
woe is me attitude,
which I had never had really had before.
And all of a sudden it's like,
why did this happen to me?
Then had a back injury and then fought,
we'll Brooks when I shouldn't have on one week,
basically one week of training,
which led to another loss,
which led to another lack of confidence and then another law.
So I went through that tough dark time,
you know,
and I think there was certain aspects of the of it that was,
it was me taking,
taking the sport for granted.
It was me taking my abilities for granted and also just not taking extreme
ownership of my mental state.
Like realizing that I might be the hardest worker in the gym.
I am the hardest worker in the gym in every gym.
I go to him,
the hardest worker.
I lived life,
right?
I do the right things.
Um,
but if you're not constantly taking extreme ownership of your mental state of
your confidence,
your self image,
I think a healthy self image is the,
um,
the most important component of being successful in life.
And I just,
I wasn't taking care of that essence.
So you were doing all the right things physically,
you weren't doing what you needed to do mentally.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think I had never visualized until after that.
honestly,
I mean,
I come from,
uh,
I come from a hardworking background.
My Mom and dad both worked two jobs.
My Dad was a union carpenter,
woke up at five in the morning every single morning,
pulled us,
pulled himself up by his bootstraps mom the same way,
working two,
three jobs,
both of them to make sure that me and my brothers had every,
every single advantage in life,
whether it be wrestling camps,
football camps,
this,
that,
the other thing.
Um,
but we weren't exactly taught that,
hey,
you can go out in the world and do great things.
You can go out and you can be not just good but great and be a champion.
And I think I went into college wrestling and I might,
I might have told the coaches I wanted to be a national champion.
I might've told the reporters,
um,
all the people that I was supposed to then I want it to be a national champion.
But in my heart of hearts,
I didn't truly believe it.
You know,
and I think,
and I was,
I mean,
you,
you ask Tyron,
you asked Ben,
um,
those guys took me under their wing because I was the hardest worker in the
room,
you know,
and they said,
man,
this guy could be good,
but I didn't exactly believe in myself.
Um,
and now it's taken me almost til I'm 30 years old to really truly believe that I
was put on this earth to do some amazing things and that there is no limits on
myself and that there is no limits to my capabilities and my abilities.
So,
I mean,
I think we underestimate how important and how mental life is.
And not just in,
not just in athletics,
not just in fighting,
not just in sports,
but I mean in anything,
in business and,
and just being a good person.
Just believing in yourself and having a healthy self image.
Yeah,
I couldn't agree more.
Um,
I think that's one of the most important things to life,
but it's also really difficult to cultivate.
Oh,
it is Bob.
Well,
I think too,
I mean,
I'm very hard on myself,
you know?
I mean,
I think anybody who's,
who's successful is,
is at least relatively hard on themselves.
And I,
I think I got to the point where I just started calling myself lazy.
You know,
I wake up every morning,
you know,
and I,
and I think,
Michael,
you're being lazy.
If you don't do something today,
listen to this podcast or watching this youtube video or read this book,
or spend 10 minutes,
five minutes,
30 minutes visualizing yourself in a cage or on a podium or having loads of
wealth or having loads of influence,
having loads of impact,
having,
having ridiculous amounts of success.
Because until you actually see it in your mind's eye,
you can't actually achieve it.
Or we are going to get to the point right on the cusp of about to be achieving
it.
And you're going to have that cognitive dissonance where something,
something pops up where you have the opportunity to break that barrier.
But you're gonna find a way to sabotage yourself because you don't truly believe
that you deserve it.
And I did that numerous times in college.
There was times where I was beaten,
um,
top rank guys in the country and would somehow find a way to lose because
winning,
to me,
being crazy successful to me wasn't exactly,
it didn't exactly Mesh with how I truly saw myself.
You know,
I think it's,
and I think I can look back on that and not with regret,
but with that kind of edge now they just educate myself and I look back and I
could put myself at national duels against CPH later,
US versus Minnesota.
My team needed me to,
when he was ranked the top five in the country,
I wasn't supposed to beat him.
I was up by two takedowns and somehow in the third period I lose the match and I
can go back and see that in my mind and realize,
okay,
that was a time,
let's say,
let's,
uh,
let's respect that for what it is and let's use that as fuel for the future.
I mean,
my last Eddie Alvarez was,
was a lot of technical,
a lot of technical things I did wrong.
Technically losses the will rooks were,
were things I did wrong technically.
Um,
but mentally I wasn't there as well.
And then I came back with a vengeance and then one,
and I've now I've one six in my last seven.
The only loss was a crazy freak injury and now we can continue to move forward
and just kind of look at it from as an adult instead of take the emotion out of
it and look at it a plus B equals c,
you know?
And so it's really kind of helped me,
I think for a lot of people who don't test themselves in such an extreme manner.
I mean,
I think MMA is probably one of the most extreme things you could do for a job
with being a soldier or a fireman or a police officer or something like that.
But it's that this idea that you sabotage yourself because you can't imagine
yourself winning.
Chael Sonnen talked about that quite a bit about his fight with Anderson Silva,
how he was,
you know,
kind of dominating him,
not kind of,
but was dominating him,
was very close to being the UFC.
Middleweight champion found a way to fall into a triangle and he had done that
with Paulo Filio when he fought him and there was this thing that he would do
where he would find a way to fuck it up.
Even though you're there doing it,
the pressure of possibly pulling it off was too overwhelming to,
you didn't build some,
some ways you didn't,
you didn't believe it.
And,
and it's not even,
I mean we're,
we're all,
I think we're all victim to our subs,
our subconscious sometimes too.
I mean,
like we said,
we're in there fighting.
You think,
okay,
that's,
that's a man in there fighting.
He,
he has control of his body.
But you,
you do,
but you don't,
I mean like when,
when Jay was getting caught,
I mean,
I know exactly what you're talking about it for everybody.
No,
the remembers that fight because we were all sitting there watching,
thinking,
holy cow,
I can't believe [inaudible] here's a couple of minutes away from being the tar
out of them,
you know,
and all of a sudden,
I think we all saw the triangle come into,
you know,
Anderson and it seemed like he'd put push the arm down real slow and then all of
a sudden through the leg over and we're all like,
what are you doing?
And then 30 seconds later he's,
you know,
or 10 seconds later the,
the fights over.
And I think it's the,
the,
your views or your beliefs not matching up with the reality and all of a sudden
there's that fine line between breaking that barrier.
And unless you have been there before,
unless like I said,
visualizing yourself,
extremely successful,
extremely wealthy.
Someone to be looked at,
someone to be admired,
someone to be,
to,
to follow.
Unless you see that you're going to get to the point where you tell everybody
you want the success,
but you're not going to get it unless you 100% truly believe in it.
And it took me 30 years to figure it out.
So anybody who's done that before you know it,
it's okay.
It will come with time.
But you really have to,
like I said,
take extreme ownership of inside your brain between your ears is the most
important part of life as we've already said.
And,
and,
and you can continue to work hard.
And I go back to the talking about being lazy.
You know,
I literally call myself lazy and you know,
shame myself.
You know,
like,
Michael,
why didn't you do this today?
Why didn't you work on your mental,
your mental health today,
your self image today?
Why didn't you visualize?
Why didn't you do that?
Because that's just just like flexing a muscle in the gym,
just like throwing a thousand repetitions,
whether it be on the punching bag or drilling or a wrestling move or a or a
takedown.
It's all the same stuff.
And arguably more important on the mental side of things and it isn't the
physical side of things.
When you keep saying extreme ownership.
Did you read Jocko is booked.
I have it.
I have,
it's one of those ones where I have it and I haven't read it yet,
but I,
I love that,
that word.
Extreme ownership.
Yeah,
it's an awesome not,
it's an awesome book too.
And it's from a guy who was actually lived it,
you know,
just a lot of,
there's a lot of wisdom in his life experiences that you can get something out
of.
Um,
I asked because you obviously are a guy who seeks out knowledge,
right?
You,
you,
you work on your mind.
What,
what was it?
Was it a book or as a series of books?
Like what,
what got you thinking differently?
Well,
honestly for me,
what got me thinking differently,
it was honestly just going through the most trying time in my life.
I mean,
I had just gotten married.
Now it's time to be a man,
now it's time to step up.
Now it's time to provide.
And all of a sudden I go through this loss streak where after my third loss,
I went home to San Diego with my wife.
We sat on the couch and we sit there and we just cried.
Who was the third loss?
Uh,
Third Wilson was we'll books the second time.
Oh,
that's right.
So,
um,
so I lost him twice,
Eddie once and then now the Madison Square Garden one.
But we went home,
we sat there and it was almost like,
what do we do now?
Is Bella tour going to cut me?
Am I,
did I work this hard to now,
you know,
be where I'm at now.
You know,
I mean,
I was at the,
I mean I was a two years or year and a half removed from being one of the top
three guys in the world had just beaten Eddie,
Eddie and you know,
all that kind of stuff.
And now here I was,
three fights in a row lost.
But it was,
it was that time where I realized,
right.
I was actually starting to change my kind of mental training and stuff.
I was starting my mental training as I was going into that third fight.
Um,
or that,
that third loss,
that second fight with a little Brooks.
Um,
but I just hadn't been there yet.
And honestly that one,
and that one was more just like I got caught,
you know?
Um,
but that,
that was really what kind of set the trigger.
And,
and I,
and I think it just started to realize,
Michael,
why you know,
you,
you sit there and you tell people you want to be the best.
You,
your,
your actions speak louder than your words.
You work harder than everybody else.
You show at first,
you're the last one to leave.
You take care of your body,
you do all the right things.
At the end of the day,
somebody has to be the best.
Why shouldn't it be?
You?
And I kept asking myself that question,
and the only answer I could come up with was,
I deserve to be the best.
I really do.
You know?
And I can say that with humility to say,
I really do deserve to be the best guy in the,
in the entire world at lightweight.
Now,
nobody works harder than I do.
Nobody takes care of themselves by than I do.
Nobody has made the sacrifices that I have and nobody lives the clean lifestyle
like I do.
And it has,
has a calling on their life like I do.
Yet when it came down to it,
it has taken years and years and decades to almost erase the small mindedness
that I've had in my past.
Um,
and we're all just a constant work in progress.
And I think I just,
I came up with work hard,
good things might happen,
but most likely it be mediocre,
you know?
That's Kinda,
that was Kinda my mindset.
But what did you do different or what,
what did you change for me yet?
Reading books.
I'm like,
what specifically,
do you remember what triggered it or what helped you?
There's a,
um,
there was a book called Mind Gym.
We were heard of it,
no mind gym.
And they talked about,
he talks about making a mental highlight reel.
And since that day,
I've made mental highlight reels every couple of months.
And even even right now to this day,
there's on my mental highlight reel right now is beating Kyler Sanderson,
um,
at Mizzou on senior night when him and I were ranked at the same,
we were ranked like fourth and fifth in the country,
you know,
and not that I wasn't supposed to be doing,
but the manner in which I beat him,
I almost majored Im.
And it was one of those breakthrough moments where I gave myself permission in
front of everybody to just go out there and beat a guy handedly.
It was a wrestling mat and it was a wrestling match,
you know.
So when you say make a mental highlight reel,
this is of your past accomplishments,
past accomplishments.
And I think the biggest detriment,
the,
the biggest detriment to the people that work hard and expect a lot of
themselves is when you have achievements,
you don't take time to smell the roses.
You don't take time to pat yourself on the back,
you feet,
you think that,
okay,
well if I,
if I,
if I stop and I said,
you know what,
I am good.
Oh my gosh,
I did do a great job.
Holy cow,
I was dominant.
You're not supposed to do that because that's prideful.
And that's,
that's,
that's conceited and that's narcicisstic.
But really,
if you're not your biggest fan,
who's going to be,
you know,
and I think that's what I always did.
I would accomplish something.
I'd say,
okay,
well I'm supposed to accomplish that.
I won this tournament while I was supposed to you.
Or there's a balance,
right?
There's a balance between patting yourself on the back too much and kissing your
own ass,
believe in your own bullshit.
And we see what happens with those guys.
That's almost worse.
Exactly.
One.
And I think,
and I think we've all seen those cases too,
you know,
we've all seen those cases where you see,
you see one guy,
pride comes before the fall and then all of a sudden the fall happens.
You say,
okay,
well I don't want to do that.
But there is that fine line that that middle ground where it's like I,
I it's okay to love yourself.
It's a don't look at yourself in the mirror and say that man right there
standing in front of me in the mirror is a bad ass and you are,
you deserve to be extremely successful.
But then when you go out in the world that you don't walk around like you're
better than people.
You don't walk around like you know,
so I mean there's,
there is no,
you know,
finite a plus B equals c type of way to live.
But there is that middle ground between being your biggest fan,
taking time to stop,
stop and Pat yourself on the back and re realize your accomplishments,
which,
which the mental highlight reel thing is something great.
Cause you can go through 10 things in your past and just continuing to remember
those times where you,
you were in your flow state where you absolutely performed at a ridiculous level
that you didn't,
that you kind of surprise yourself almost.
And I think that continues to happen step by step and brick by boring brick.
You make these little bitty accomplishments and as long as you continue to
remember them,
you can continue to increase that
confidence capacity that you had,
that you should have in queue and start to go from,
man,
I didn't know what was capable of this to now the confident expectancy of,
okay I said I deserve it,
but now I really am starting to believe that I deserve it.
And then once you actually believe,
then you get no scenarios where it's you versus him and someone's got to win.
So it's you more most of the time now.
So this flow state thing,
so like when you are in a state where you feel like everything is just clicking,
do you try to,
how do you try to recreate that in your mind to remember that state?
I think it's,
I think it,
it is writing things down after practice or,
or honestly sometimes what I like to do is you do that,
you're like come a journal,
a trading journal,
try to write things down.
I mean,
and,
and that's,
that's things too that can be added to a mental highlight reel,
you know,
like go like having a really great sparring day and then remembering what you
had for breakfast,
remembering how your,
how your day started.
Remember whether you did or did not watch the TV before practice or you know,
those little things.
And then,
and then I always talk about working extremely hard and surround yourself with
the best people possible.
And that's why I've,
you know,
I moved out to Las Vegas right when I started fighting and then moved to San
Diego and then move and then move my training camp to Arizona.
And then now Florida and now,
you know,
so I've moved all over the country to find the best guys I possibly can.
So when you have a great day like that,
sit down with the coaches and say,
hey coach,
you know,
talking to Henry or Evan or call me or,
or one of these guys that has coached me right now and talk about it,
like almost overly talk about it,
which that,
those guys are always annoying to me.
Are,
they always used to be like,
Hey,
I did this right and I did this right,
and it did disrupt because I always thought,
well,
you should just work.
You shouldn't talk,
just work.
But I,
I've started to realize that those things need to be vocalized or they get swept
under the rug and you forget that you had a great day.
So now we sit down and we'd talk and we say,
hey man,
that that three to was really,
really working great off the faint and we work that we worked at yesterday as we
were hitting mitts and now you're continuing to show yourself that this thing
really actually does work.
You're not just working to work,
you're working smart,
and then you see,
you see that working smart actually turns into results and then you're,
you're,
you're like a lab rat in the gym working on these little experiments that
that you're making and you're actually collecting the data and seeing the
results.
No.
When you're talking about doing a mental highlight reel thing,
is this sort of a,
a rebuilding exercise,
a rebuilding confidence exercise or is this just a solidifying skillset and
understanding your potential?
Cause you've already done things before like,
cause you were in a bad spot when you started doing this and you,
is this when you started constructing this highlight reel thing?
That's what,
yeah,
that's when it,
that's when I really,
I actually read the book and in college and then found it on my shelf one day.
Do you know who wrote it?
Mind gym suit.
You find a Jimmy Gary Mack.
Mack.
Gary Mack.
Sorry man.
Yeah.
And then there was just a bunch of,
and there was another book,
um,
to remind or remind me.
It's called how champions think.
Um,
but,
and it was just a bunch of,
a bunch of instances where they were talking about tiger woods and they were
talking
about this guy or that guy,
you know?
And then one of the chapters was doing a mental highlight reel.
And I think it can be used for both.
I mean,
no,
I mean you should do one.
Today,
we should all do one today.
Whether you're in a great place,
whether you're just you just closed the biggest business deal you ever possibly
could or you just are down in the dumps because you feel like the biggest loser
on earth,
you do a mental highlight reel to just,
it's,
it's just like going to the gym and then it changes.
You know,
maybe maybe this month is different than next month.
Maybe you wipe off an old one and you put on a brand new one that you just
remembered it because sometimes we forget successes that we have.
It takes,
it takes me going to my Wikipedia page or me going on some old interviews or,
or somebody telling me on Twitter,
hey,
remember that time he did this for me to actually remember the successes that
I've had because I've been conditioned to pull myself up by my bootstraps every
single day and forget about all my accomplishes in my past because those don't
matter.
Those are stumbling those what I used to look as stumbling blocks because what
got you here isn't going to get you where,
where you want to go.
And we have that some sort of that,
that mentality.
But you have to take the time to remember and almost look at yourself the way
other people see you.
Because we all are,
are,
are all our biggest critics.
You know,
the way my fans see me,
the way you watch me fight is,
and,
and the,
the,
the way you see my abilities is probably even better than I have seen myself a
lot in my past.
From an outside perspective,
it's so much easier to look at someone outside perspective because our own inner
monologue or our own and our own self image dummies down who we are and,
and how much we went to accomplish it.
Not all of us.
I mean,
there's a lot of people out there who are cocky,
narcissistic,
narcissistic people who think they are the,
you know,
those people have the hardest time coming back from losses the big time because
when they get head kicked or something and then they realize they're human,
it's like whoa.
You see it with a lot of those guys where they don't,
instead of facing their demons,
what they've done is create this delusional,
delusional self image.
And when that delusional self image gets shattered and it's an undeniable
reality that there's people that are better than them,
it's very,
very difficult for them to bounce back.
Yeah.
Well,
and I mean I think I am by no means the poster child for for that.
I mean it,
it took me a loss that carried me into another loss and another loss.
It was a,
I went 688 days without a win and I'll never,
but when I write a book,
some days it was Sunday is going to be called 688 days and that's how long it
took me to go from loss to win.
And that's a long,
that's a long fucking time,
long time to be,
to question yourself every single day to wake up in the morning wondering if you
were going to have a paycheck,
wondering if you were going to get a phone call from her manager,
wondering if you really wanted to open up your phone and see all the negative
comments that I told you.
Michael Chandler wasn't as good as we all thought he was.
[inaudible] you know,
that,
you know,
but I mean,
not even,
you know,
not even just the fans.
It was,
you know,
the media wrote me off [inaudible] everybody you and you know,
the,
you're,
you're just,
you get written off and,
and it's,
it,
it shapes the reality when really the reality was,
man,
I was put on this earth to do some great things,
but it just took me,
I look,
I look at it now and I think,
you know,
if bad things happen to you,
but a good things come,
a good thing comes from,
it wasn't really a bad thing.
And I look at it and I say,
everybody's got losses.
It's not a big deal.
You know,
I remember the sting,
I remember the pain.
I remember the embarrassment.
I mean,
what we also got to remember too is this is embarrassing.
You lose a fight.
That's embarrassing you hard pill to swallow.
Yeah.
You know,
so it's,
it's tough,
especially when you were a former champion and then you're going these 600 plus
days without a win and that's,
it really highlights the difficult nature of fighting as opposed to any other
sport where,
you know,
there's,
there's times where it's entirely likely that you're going to go a long time
without competing again.
Yeah.
You could go six months without competing again.
You can go eight months,
guys go a year.
If you get injured,
that's a long fucking time.
Any other sport,
if you lose a baseball game,
you know,
you drop a ball,
like you're back at it next day,
the next day.
Same thing with wrestling.
You know,
wrestling,
wrestling was great because you know,
you,
you lost it.
You lost a match on Saturday.
You were able to,
to come back and the dual on Wednesday or even the next Saturday,
seven days you had to go.
You know what I mean?
A lot of times,
yeah,
I mean,
barring injuries or whatnot,
it could be a year before you get to get to step back in the cage again and then
every single day you spend questioning and every single day you also just end up
putting so much pressure on yourself.
I mean,
my,
the biggest thing that I did wrong was I came into this sport.
I wasn't,
and literally the 18 months after starting the sport,
I was in a cage with Eddie Alvarez,
top five guy in the world,
beat Eddie Alvarez.
Then it was like,
okay,
now you have to perform.
That was that.
Soon after starting the sport,
uh,
August of 2009 I had my first fight and then I fought him in 2011.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
And he finished him and finished him,
but,
but then,
but then now the,
now the real game starts.
Now it's like,
okay,
hey,
you're there.
You're ranked in the top three,
top five,
you know,
your whole future depends on every single fight.
And then instead of thinking about every single fight,
you think about every single practice.
And instead of thinking about every single practice,
you think about every single round in practice and that not just every round,
but every minute in practice.
So you hit me,
you hit me with a one to immediately,
that's a loss in my mind.
So now I have to come back and get it,
you know?
So instead of just focusing on success,
I was focusing on perfection.
So every single day I was trying to be perfect.
You can't be perfect.
The greatest athletes in the world will tell you they are not perfect.
You know,
they fail time and time and time again.
But I'd put all this pressure on myself to where I put myself in this prison of
Michael,
you suck because you just lost to this guy who's not even signed to at any
organization at all.
And you just lost to him in,
in this,
in the sparring round.
In My,
my view of,
of what the loss was was different than my coach who watched it.
He said,
no you did all right and you didn't lose horribly.
But in my mind I lost horribly.
I would've got finished bubble ball.
That kind of like crazy stuff,
you know.
Um,
so that's the thing too is I started focusing on success and our perfection,
you know,
stop putting so much pressure on yourself to be perfect.
Just focus on being successful.
Now I'm focusing on the big picture of being successful instead of these little
bitty instances where I'm trying to be perfect.
Now when you look at yourself and you look you overall MMA skillset,
do you uh,
do try to look at it almost like as if you're managing yourself,
not managing yourself like a fight manager,
but like,
like a project like looking at it like,
okay,
this is what we need to work on.
This is how I need to tighten this up and tight.
Do you,
do you look at it as like an overall long term project?
Like how do you,
how do you visualize it?
Yeah,
I mean in,
and I get that question a lot too,
is like,
well hey,
how much,
how do you prepare for an opponent?
And honestly I'd say almost 90% of my training is focusing on myself.
I mean,
cause if I,
if I put the right systems in place,
if I get the right sales skill sets is sharp as they can be for fight night.
There's not a guy in the lightweight division in the entire world that I think
can beat me that last 10% 90% focused on myself.
The last 10% focused on the little intricacies,
the little habits,
the little,
the little tendencies that my opponents might have.
I mean,
Eddie did a great job with it in the second round.
They knew if they ran from me in the second fight.
Yeah,
they ran from me and they circled and circled and circled crazy maniac robot
come forward like a reckless abandoned Michael Chandler is going to come and
he's gonna eat a thousand you know,
eat a thousand jabs and you can keep them off you long enough to hopefully maybe
when decision,
they did a good job at that.
I wasn't cutting off the,
I wasn't cutting off the case.
I wasn't using my faints.
I was starting to trying to throw big shots because why we had that epic battle
in 2011 I wasn't a hundred percent confident in my training.
So that led me to just fight like a barbarian rather than a skillful veteran
that has the skills and the abilities to be able to go out there and beat any
lightweight in the world.
And you know,
so I think that's a relatively new,
with your finding experience too,
right?
Well that time,
your second fight,
but I was still very young and I had changed.
I had moved to a training camp where I wasn't getting,
we all,
we all need to look at ourselves to or not.
I'm not telling people how to live their lives are trained,
but I needed to focus on a certain path to victory.
Find the easiest path to victory.
Bruce Lee,
you know,
water,
be like water,
you know,
I mean adapt,
but also just say,
okay,
I'm a not a long,
not a long guy,
not a tall guy.
I'm a shorter,
powerful wrestler who can take anybody down who's not going to get taken down,
who has an overhand right that can knock,
knock anybody out in the entire world and a gas tank that can,
that can come,
that will surpass any 25 minutes that I need to fight.
So I needed to focus on these certain five elements to be successful and not a
thousand stuff.
I mean,
training with Dominick Cruz and working on footwork and doing this and doing
that rollouts and all that kind of stuff,
it just,
it wasn't the right path to victory for me.
Therefore,
I found myself almost out training myself.
I was training so much when if I were to really just want to trained basics and
good cardio or strength and conditioning,
good boxing,
good wrestling,
good grappling.
That's easy to say now it
is a fact.
Right and duck in that.
Yeah.
Where were you training at the time were you're training on alliance?
And do you,
so you felt like you were trying to mimic like Dominic's crazy movement and I
think it's just,
I mean the good thing about that training camp is they have,
they have opened themselves up to a lot of different techniques.
You know,
I mean I,
I,
I feel like I'm pretty athletic.
I feel like I catch on pretty quickly.
But really to be successful,
like if I was going to step into the cage with Khabib tomorrow,
I'm going to focus on the basics that win.
I mean,
you can win a whole fight with a one,
two and good takedown defense,
some takedown offense and some good grappling,
you know?
And that's it.
That's all you need.
And in my mind,
the more I try to make this an intricate sport and a complicated sport,
the more you're going to find yourself having incremental defeats.
You know?
Like when I'm,
when I'm sparring outside of my element,
all of a sudden I find,
okay,
I tried this this round and I got beat up,
you know,
and got beat up.
Which messes up your confidence and all that stuff.
Do you feel like,
and this is something that I struggle with too,
when trying to analyze fighters,
performances and their future and what you can and can't do,
do,
do you feel like you go into MMA with a certain skill set you,
you started out as a wrestler and you know you're not going to be like a karate
expert.
Yeah.
Right.
You're not going to be a wonder boy.
You're not going to be a Jujitsu expert,
which you are as powerful wrestler with great striking.
That's your,
that's your skill set.
You're strong and you got great cardio.
If you tried to add a bunch of stuff to that and expand your skill level,
do you feel like there's enough time in a career to really achieve that type of
proficiency with say like kickboxing or something like that,
that a real worldclass kickboxer has the almost we're are better off not doing
that.
Yeah,
I mean that,
I mean I think I am the how to manual for that,
you know,
and,
but,
but I also do try to do different,
I mean just to too many,
too many angles to many different combinations.
Too many,
too many calls.
I mean you can also a coach can out coach to,
you know,
I mean a coach can out coach and say,
tell you seven different combinations in one minute when really it should just
been focused on cutting him off,
focus on focus on faints,
focus on touching the leg,
which is going to set up the set up,
the uh,
the punches and focus on the punches are going to set up the take down.
You know?
I mean,
I also would say now say like my coach Henri Hooft awesome kickboxing,
awesome kickboxing coach has amazing techniques,
but it's very,
very,
very basic.
We,
we focus on being very,
very proficient and very violent with the basics.
You know what I mean?
You're not going to see us throwing a bunch of crazy combinations or a budget,
a bunch of crazy stuff.
Um,
so that works very well for me.
I started out with Gil Martinez in Vegas,
just wrestling,
just boxing,
you know.
Um,
and then I went to alliance and the now down in Florida with,
with Henry.
And you live in Florida?
No,
no.
I live in Nashville,
but my last three camps I've done down in Florida,
um,
I'm opening up my own gym in Nashville.
So I will be doing training at both places.
But I mean,
the,
the killers that I get to spar with and train with don in Florida can't be
matched in,
in those coaches are amazing down there.
So yeah,
I'm a big fan of Henri Hooft.
Yeah,
it's good.
I like him as a person and I really liked his coaching style.
He's an animal.
He is.
And the funny thing is he coached against me in that second Eddie Alvarez fight.
You know,
so like we talk about that and that's why I will always,
I want to fight 80 against so bad.
I want to have that one I had that was waiting for,
that felt modified.
Eddie so bad.
But I have so much respect for him because not only did I spend,
I spent 50 minutes inside the cage with the guy.
We both have our face bloodied and battered and stitches.
I mean I got stitches in my lip.
We both have stitches in our lip and our eyes and eyebrows from each other.
Um,
but it's funny because when I sit there and I talked to people that I trained
and I basically trained in his training camp that he used to train in and
everybody always said,
there's only one guy compare your work at.
I can compare your work ethic to your dedication,
to your love for your family,
your love for the sport,
this,
that,
and the other thing.
And that's Eddie.
So,
I mean me and Eddie have have spoken a couple times.
I went up and trained with Frankie Edgar for two weeks,
um,
a couple of years ago and he was out there training.
So we like,
it's always just funny between me and him because we have fought and you know,
but it's funny but it's not like we have so much respect.
We don't hate each other.
You guys hang out and go to dinner or anything.
We never done that.
But I mean we saw each other at practice and I asked him to spar and he's like,
Nah man,
I don't want to get knocked out.
And I made that up.
But,
but we were the same.
We we're at the same thing and uh,
saint practices and stuff and it's kind of,
but you also get,
it's cool to get com compared to a guy that you have fog because that
immediately gives you that a much more respect for somebody.
Cause cause I know how hard I train.
I know I show up early and I'm always doing the little bit of extra and
everybody knows what I'm fighting for.
And I think him and I are very similar in that kind of,
in that respect.
So it's Kinda cool.
Yeah.
I would imagine no one knows each other better than you guys do after something
like that.
It's pretty nuts.
Yeah.
I mean,
and,
and man,
yeah,
they were both knocked down,
drag out wars.
They were crazy.
I would still say I won the second second fight,
but a very close fight I will say.
But,
but like I said,
I mean I ran into too many punches.
Um,
you know,
it was,
it was kind of crazy too.
I think I actually spoke to one of the refs,
one of the reps who,
who called the fight for Eddie or not one of the restaurant of the judges,
like a couple months after I was at some event and he's like,
oh yeah,
well he rocked you in the second round.
And I was like,
he didn't rock me in the second round.
I tripped,
I basically like tripped and it looked like I got rocked.
Right.
So it's just funny that kind of stuff to this,
this sport is left up to the necessarily know what they're doing.
That too.
Yeah.
That's a real problem with me.
I go crazy.
Like I remember you talking about a couple fights ago,
he kept saying the one navy.
Yeah.
You're like,
we're not going to say that lady alone.
She's a nice lady.
But look,
man,
it's,
it's just a disgrace that you have people that really don't
know anything about martial arts and they're judging martial arts competitions.
I mean,
could you imagine if you had like an ultimate fighting championship,
uh,
eight man tournament with all the judges and have them fight each other.
Right.
He'd be like,
why in the fuck is going on here?
Yeah.
You guys don't even train.
You don't know anything about fighting at all.
They take,
what do they take a test,
one test,
you know,
I mean,
a lot of them in certain commissions come from boxing.
So they're,
they're boxing judges would even then,
where are they boxers or did they test a good question.
A lot of them.
No,
no,
I'm beat.
But I think like,
I don't know if Harold Letterman can box.
It does a great job of judging though.
I mean I agree with a lot of his assessments,
but I think boxing is more straightforward.
It's two hands.
Yeah.
You know,
there's no elbows,
knees take downs.
You don't have to understand Jujitsu.
You don't have to understand wrestling.
You don't,
you don't have to understand when a guy's in trouble versus the guy's not in
trouble in a certain position.
Like how close was that submission?
You know,
what,
how many leg kicks is that guy eaten?
Why did he switch his stance?
These switches dance cause he does it all the time.
Or as his left leg chewed up,
you know,
they don't know.
They really don't know stuff that you're saying that,
that people who have seen this border our thinking,
but the judges or have,
you know,
may,
may or may not have any idea of what's going on with them.
A lot of them don't.
You have an idea.
It's a disgrace.
It really is a disgrace.
It's crazy to think that we have sports been around for 20 years now,
25 years now,
and we're still having this conversation.
Yeah.
Boxing has questionable judgments.
Like there's,
there's some questionable calls,
but nothing like MMA.
I think MMA is,
it's disgraceful.
The worst,
you know,
the worst one in your opinion.
Why wouldn't want an,
I wouldn't want to say oh,
worst one because there's been so many fucking terrible ones.
Sometimes it's like a split decision.
Well you'll,
you'll hear one,
you agree with one,
you agree with and one you're like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
And we'll like look at each other.
Like I'll look at Amac and I'll look at DC and we were like,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
How the fuck did someone think that person won that fight?
It's just bad man.
It's just really,
really,
really bad.
And for a God like you who,
you know,
you have a win bonus and a show bonus in the UFC.
So if you're in there and you do everything right and you get robbed,
you didn't just get robbed of a decision.
And on your record it goes to the lock.
And you could,
you know,
you could protest it til the cows come home.
Nobody ever gets anything reversed.
When's the last time anybody got a decision reversed?
Yeah.
I can't even remember now.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't really think it happens.
Did they rob you of your wind bonus?
I mean,
it could cost you tens of thousands if not hundreds of thousands of dollars.
It's a fucking terrible,
terrible disgrace.
Yeah,
I mean,
and,
and also too,
I've never really even thought about the financials of it.
I never really thought it was always,
to me it was like a wrestling match.
It was a loss.
It was a loss of my record.
And then now I look back and I think,
Dang man,
if I would've fought just a little bit different here or that,
or that judge would have saw
this with a little bit different and we're talking a lot of money that I could
have in my pocket or would have won,
you know?
So it's,
we've discussed this many times and I think first of all,
the idea of three judges is ridiculous.
Why?
Why only three?
Are they expensive?
Like how fucking you,
you could get some of the best martial arts practitioners in the world to judge
fights and have 10 of them.
And I bet you would have a correct outcome way more often than you would with
three.
Yeah.
You know,
and I just think we need to overhaul that and for whatever reason they're
reluctant to do so.
Um,
we talked about before this podcast started,
we talked about weight classes.
I think that's another giant issue.
Yeah.
I think every 10 pounds is a legitimate compromise.
And I think what we have now,
like the one 85 to two oh five pound gap is just bananas,
20 pounds of between world championship weight classes.
Like,
yeah,
it was just nuts.
You're dealing with two different size humans.
It's just so different.
Completely.
Yeah.
I mean,
and yeah,
I mean obviously closer to home for me would be that one 65 ish,
you know,
I mean,
and there's so many competitors are so many,
just the average human being has between one 50 and one night.
You know,
there's the big guys,
there's a small guys,
but we're kind of in that mid range,
you know,
and I think,
uh,
one 65 weight class for a lot of us at one 55,
um,
I mean I would always probably stay at one 55.
I would love some,
some cool matchups at one 65 and be able to try to go for different belts and
all that kind of stuff.
Obviously that would be great.
But,
um,
one 55 is great for me.
Um,
but there's definitely,
I know some guys who were missing waits Shell Kevin lead two weeks ago.
Miss Weight.
It could be because obviously missed weight numerous times,
but could be Biz.
You know,
he's a big guy when he gets down to one 55 that is quite a cut.
And since he's been,
I believe he's with George Lockhart,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
Um,
well it wasn't him and Tony Martin,
Him and Tony both with Lockhart,
and then they dropped the fight right before Tony got hurt.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
I thought that was,
I think that's the case.
Um,
I mean there's a lot of great experts,
Mike Dolce of course,
there's a lot of great experts in getting you down to the the proper way.
But the bottom line is when you're coming down from 200 pounds and you're
getting down to one 55,
that's a fucking struggle.
It is lot.
Yeah.
I mean,
and,
and like we talked about too,
it depends on,
you know,
cause everybody,
that's always the question I get from all kinds of equal,
hey,
what,
what weight do you walk around at?
And it's not really the weight,
it's the body composition.
How much,
you know,
how much body fat are you holding?
You know,
I mean,
I get a Dexa scan,
um,
every couple months when I'm down in Florida or whatnot.
We always try to stress a Dexa scan.
How does that work?
So you basically,
it's the one where you lay down as the one they have with the dance institute in
UFC probably.
It's just the thing that goes awry for five seconds.
And it does everything from,
from water to bone density to muscles,
tendons,
ligaments to Oregon's like all of that kind of stuff.
And the cool thing is my bone density has continued to go up like over the last
couple of years.
You know,
how much,
I mean it's,
it's point 0.01% or whatever.
But I mean that's,
that's a lot when you're talking about bone density.
And is that from strength training?
I think so.
I mean,
I put it,
I put out a post
a couple months ago where I really think,
you know,
I've been extremely blessed to have a throughout college wrestling.
I mean I've seen so many talented guys,
careers ended because of injuries.
I had none.
You know,
I had a couple of sprains here and there.
I had a meniscus tear,
whatnot.
There's are like six weekends here.
He's no big deal.
Same thing in,
in,
in mixed martial arts.
I haven't really had any really bad injuries and I really do think it's because
I keep my body in great shape and I do a lot of strength training.
Like my body is constantly overcompensating for the weights that I'm throwing
around the med balls and I'm throwing around the,
the comfort zone,
getting my skin in my body outside of my comfort zone and day in and day out
that my body is just kind of bulletproof itself to,
you know,
a lot of serious injuries.
Obviously it's fights.
I mean it's a fighting and you know,
you're,
you're jacking up little limbs in hands and feet and all that kind of stuff here
and there all the time.
But nothing serious.
Cam Haynes went,
worked out with you and one of your strength conditioning workouts.
Who was your,
your strength coach for that?
That was a Todd Durkin and San Diego fitness quest 10.
So that was,
uh,
that was something he had just Skype.
He was doing skydiving that morning yet with Andy Stone and he,
uh,
he wanted to come in for a workout and yeah,
we went through,
I mean,
a lot of my stuff is not crazy heavy.
Um,
but it's just a lot of reps,
a lot of cardio,
a lot of,
a lot of moving stuff around,
a lot of functional movements.
And we have,
what kind of stuff are you doing now?
I Love Med ball stuff.
I Love Med ball slams,
med ball rotations.
I love anything.
What I always focus on his strength plus speed equals power.
So we'll do one strength movement,
whether it's a,
whether it's a dead lift,
you know,
a trap bar,
dead lift,
or a squat straight into a speed movement,
which would be like just a plyometric squat jump.
So you've got the strength plus the speed and that's how you continue to gain
power in supersets,
you know,
so then,
so that maybe we're doing a bench press,
you know,
bench press isn't the greatest workout,
but it's focusing on the punching power.
Just three reps of something,
a little bit heavy dumbbells or barbells,
barbells and dumbbells.
Right.
To a plyometric pushup.
So now you've got another strength plus a speed equals power.
So plyometric pushup,
meaning you explode up.
Yeah.
And do you clapping at the top like how you,
you could,
yeah,
you could.
You don't have to.
I mean,
a lot of times it's just exploding as hard as you can and then catching yourself
exploding as hard as you can.
Um,
and we do a lot of that kind of stuff,
whether it's,
you know,
squats to hurdle jumps or dead lifts to,
um,
Med ball slam to jump,
you know,
I mean,
we're always,
and that also gets your heart rate up.
It's also just getting your body moving like crazy.
So I mean,
a lot of the stuff we're doing at my,
at my new gym,
a lot of that programming is,
is very similar to that,
where we have like a ripped class where it's resistance interval power,
plyometric and is there an endurance and we're focusing on all those things.
Everybody likes to do that.
They'd like to make it an acronym.
Yeah,
beloved love doing that was my boy PJ.
That was my,
what?
My bug PJ at Jenny Kim and I loved it though.
Was like ripped.
What is that?
And then I was like,
wow.
All right.
P P e.
D.
I love it.
So yeah,
talk about that.
Yeah.
People like that because you can remember it,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
now when you are going into a camp,
who
organizes your training?
Like how do you,
how do you decide when you're doing strength and conditioning?
When you're doing skill work,
when you're sparring,
when you're recuperating?
It's a,
it's always a little bit different.
I mean,
and the last couple of camps out in Florida,
we've had pretty much the same kind of schedule.
You know,
we,
we're,
Monday morning is always a drill.
Tuesday is sparring,
Wednesday was wrestling,
Thursday was,
Thursday was grappling,
Friday was sparring.
And then at night we go more individual,
whether it's individual with,
uh,
one of the,
one of the kickboxing coaches,
one of the mid,
one of the MIT coaches with the either Henry or Evan or maybe it's a one on one
with Kami Barzini or maybe it's a one on one with Greg Jones or it's a one on
one with,
um,
uh,
grappling coach or it's your strength and conditioning.
A lot of times I coupled them where I'll do an hour with,
I'll do an hour of strength work with 30 or 45 minutes of,
of pads as well.
You know,
where it all depends on the recovery,
you know what I mean?
If I,
if I feel myself getting overworked,
I will cut one of those out and focus on which one's more important for that
particular fight.
You know?
I mean if I,
if I,
I was fighting Goatee Yamauchi who's a big time grappler,
big time submission artists.
So I focused a lot more on escapes,
um,
defense submission,
defense and all that kind of stuff.
I was still focusing on strength and conditioning and striking,
but I really threw in an extra couple of grappling sessions there,
you know,
so it's,
so who's managing all of this though?
Do you have a,
a head coach that decides what you're going to do?
What?
And they'd look at you and say,
you know,
today we're going to take it easier today.
We're going to do this.
I think,
I mean,
it's,
it's that kind of loose schedule that we always have.
But Henry Henry said that Henry and,
and Kami Barzini has come in and really helped,
um,
helped manage some of that stuff.
We made a couple of different changes.
Um,
but I mean,
yeah,
they come in and they say,
here's,
here's what we're going to do.
But then every now and then it's like,
hey,
tonight instead of,
you know,
instead of an hour long,
we're going to do 30 with 30 with me and then 30 with Kami or Henry him would do
30 but 30 minutes of pads,
30 minutes with comedy.
So it's,
it ebbs and flows.
And I think one of the biggest things about mixed martial arts is it's an
individual sport,
right?
We're all grown men.
We all have our coaches that were supposed to listen to,
but I don't have to,
I don't have to do it.
They don't have to do it.
Any of these guys telling me too.
But I think that's why wrestlers are so successful because they show up,
they shut up and you tell me what to do.
And you asked me how,
how high to jump,
and I just jump,
you know?
Yeah.
I've always said that.
I think there's two aspects of wrestling that make it the most important
skillset to have an MMA.
And one of them is the ability to take a fight to the ground or stand back up.
Like just to have that,
to have the ability to dictate where the fight takes places gigantic.
But to who's Mike maybe just as important is the mental strength.
Wrestlers are always dehydrated.
They're always exhausted,
they're always pushing and there they take pride in being the most miserable
person.
Yeah.
You know,
there's something about that,
like it be having the ability to push through discomfort,
which is just something that you cultivate
in a,
in a amateur wrestling career.
Yeah.
I mean you just get,
I think you just get so comfortable being uncomfortable.
Like your,
your life sucks for five years straight,
especially division one,
college wrestling.
I mean,
and it's,
it's an emotional rollercoaster.
I mean with that mental toughness that you're talking about,
you don't just get mentally tough from,
from working hard.
You get mentally tough from working hard and losing and then winning and then
losing and then having coach riding your but because of this and then you got to
final and you've got to test and you got this and you've got all this hold this
whole life that you're trying to manage and figure out while you're still trying
to become a national champion.
So you're getting thrown into the hardest sport in the entire world,
physically,
the hardest sport mentally plus trying to do,
you know,
have a college career actually get your degree,
the whole reason you went to college.
Um,
and then really just being coachable and understanding delayed gratification.
I think so many people can come into an MMA gym and they have a great boxing
coach and it's like they expect after the first mid session that they're going
to look like Roy Jones Jr.
Whereas when I showed up to MMA,
I realized,
okay,
I went to Vegas and I was training with Gray Maynard,
didn't Mike Pyle and Jay here on and Tyson Griffin and Evan Dunham and all
these,
all these great guys.
I knew I was going to take my licks for a long time.
It might've been a year before I went around.
I was okay with that.
You have to be okay with the delayed gratification of life and that's,
and now even at a 32 year old,
as a 32 year old,
I understand that any aspect of life that I'm going into that's new.
It's okay if I'm the guppy.
It's okay if I'm the lowest guy on the Totem Pole,
even though I've accomplished so many great things and um,
you know,
and I,
and I've done some great things in life.
I still,
I'm still a guppy in a lot of,
a lot of aspects of life.
You know,
it's,
that's a hard pill for a lot of people to swallow.
It is kick boxers never learned Jujitsu.
They hate getting tapped and hello getting tapped.
It's never happened actually,
but now,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
you've seen it.
we've all seen it got us a fantastic kickboxers that for whatever reason they
just try to concentrate only on defense.
It's all they want to do.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm not one of those guys that I get tapped and I'm like,
Oh man,
good job man.
I'm ripping tick.best.
But,
but that doesn't mean I'm not gonna show up the next day.
That doesn't mean I'm going to,
I mean,
the funniest thing is you go to any gym or around the country if they have,
I bet you asked DC this at,
at Aka,
he's running the wrestling practice.
I bet the amount of guys that show up for sparring day and grappling day is
different than the guys who show up on wrestling day.
Same thing at our gym.
We'll have 28 guys,
30 guys sparring on,
on Tuesday,
all sudden Wednesday rolls around and we're doing a group,
a wrestling practice,
and there's like seven guys that show up.
You know,
it's a fucking,
and it's hard,
you know,
buck and hard,
but you have to embrace the suck.
You have to understand that you don't get anything in life without getting
yourself outside of your comfort zone,
right?
Every single thing that you want to accomplish is waiting for you right outside
of your comfort zone.
And that's what I've really started to realize.
And you just take ownership,
extreme ownership of of it and say,
stop being,
stop being a sissy and just go push yourself to your puke.
Have you ever puked?
Have you ever passed out?
No.
You haven't.
You know,
or you haven't passed out.
I rarely Puke,
so I want to just continue,
try to get myself there and if I can,
I'm doing something right now.
When you say visualization and you say you visualize,
how do you do it and what do you do?
You schedule a time like,
hey,
you know,
8:00 PM tonight after training,
I'm going to sit down and I'm going to visualize for an hour.
Yeah,
there needs to be a time.
I mean first of all,
you all,
you always want to try to set a time you,
you can never say I'll definitely do it tomorrow.
You need to say,
okay well have I have practice here,
I have practice here,
I need to eat here.
I have an interview here,
I have this year that their car out.
It doesn't need to be a crazy amount of time.
I mean you know,
five,
five minutes is long enough.
That's a long time to be,
I mean that's all round.
Do you ever give a grapple around in two minutes goes by,
you look at the clock and there's three minutes left.
Temple is holy cow.
Like you know a five minutes is a long time cause you can get a lot done
mentally cause cause visualization knows no time.
There's not a clock ticking.
You know there's things happening.
There's so you close your eyes when you do this.
Where are you sitting in you sitting in a dark room?
Like how do you do those?
Sometimes it's,
I mean the hard part with me is I'm a very good sleeper.
Like,
I've,
I've tried to be like,
I'm going to wake up in the morning and I'm going to keep laying in bed and
visualize it and fall asleep,
you know,
like,
so you got to know yourself,
you know that he's good though.
At least at least you're getting sleep for sure.
Yeah.
You gotta I mean,
you've got to have the self awareness to know where,
where you're on,
where you're off,
you know?
So for me,
I mean a lot of times it's sitting up,
sitting on,
sitting on the couch,
sitting on a chair.
Um,
but I think the biggest thing is,
is,
is seeing,
seeing the lights.
I mean the other day for instance,
like I was just,
we were just talking about Fuji and putting in the maths and so we just,
we just installed a,
a bag rack system in my gym and something there.
I don't know if it was the rubber,
the cage panels or what it was and it smelled exactly like the bell tore cage.
And I started to get,
I got like,
I literally my hearts heart rate started going up and I got goosebumps because
of a smell.
You get triggered.
Yes.
That's what it is.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I know exactly what that smell is.
Um,
that's weird.
I'll smells do that.
Oh,
100%.
I,
and I've,
I've almost,
I've actually asked Bella or,
Hey,
can I have a piece of that cage I want to cut off to smell eight inch piece of
that cage,
the canvas or whatever it is to bring in.
Just just suck it in a huff coach huff cage.
But you gotta get your,
you got to get yourself to their,
you know,
um,
and,
and be in the,
in the space,
in the arena.
I can see the cage.
And after I started doing it,
I mean,
it was the tricky pit bull fight,
the knockout where that was the first time that I had really,
really gotten,
I had really made the head hit that breakthrough where I walked into the cage
that me,
Joe,
I hated fighting.
I didn't really like it that much because I,
I wasn't myself.
I wasn't present.
I wasn't literally a caged animal and I hated the way I felt.
I was peeing blood after fights because I was just going so crazy and I was
just,
and obviously I gained a lot of fans because people loved the way I fight,
but they didn't exactly care about my wellbeing that much but right.
But it wasn't until that fight where I got into the cage and I just started
smiling because I thought,
Michael,
this is your home.
Like this is your home.
Because I had visualized it so much because the problem with we talked about
earlier is you only get to compete every six months,
every three months.
You don't know what that actually feels like.
And you can,
you can show up to the venue early and you can walk around it.
You can smell the smells,
but it's,
there's nothing like competing in the cage.
There's nothing.
You can't recreate it in sparring.
You can't recreate it in the gym.
The only really place you can recreate it is in your mind.
If you,
if you just continue to remember,
I can remember my last fight like it like it was yesterday cause I've actually
gotten better at the skill of visualization because I think that's one thing
that happens too is you sit down and maybe you're listening to this podcast and
like,
okay,
I'm going to smell the smells of this.
I don't to see the sights of this.
And then you have a really not great visualization session.
You're like,
man that was stupid.
That guy's an idiot,
you know?
But it really does take,
it really does.
Take a second and let us take actual practice too to see and smell and hear and
feel like you need,
you need to see yourself getting put in compromising situations and,
and then see yourself getting out of it.
You know,
you need to see,
you need to see yourself,
um,
performing at a ridiculously high level and how that's going to feel and how and
how,
how your brain is a is a hundred percent bulletproof and how your,
how your heart rate is where it needs to be and how you are somehow confidently
composed during that.
During those fights,
you know,
because it used to be,
I would,
the bell would ring and I would go a thousand miles an hour.
And The Times that you've seen me exhausted and fights,
I mean I passed out,
literally passed out in a fight before,
right at the route,
right at the end of the round.
Thank God it was at the end of the round.
Henry who've came,
picked me up,
my feet were like a pigeon toed.
I couldn't,
he was like dragging me back to my corner.
I sat down in the cage because I watched the video and all of a sudden my coach
out here woke me up.
I heard his voice and I turned around and I literally,
it was a,
the Benson Henderson fight.
Wow.
I literally thought the fight was over and I asked him,
I said,
did I just get finished as this fight over?
And he said,
no man,
you gotta go,
go,
go into the know what happened?
Did you get hit?
Um,
what,
what was it was,
it was in the Benson Henderson fight going into the fifth round.
We are in that weird,
I have this thing where I,
I actually like to get,
um,
you know that one,
that one move where you're,
you're basically like this and he,
and they catch your,
your arm with the leg and then Chris suffix.
Yes.
And mounted that one where I remember the old school where that guy's got elbow
to know him,
but I do a backflip over top and,
and,
and I always land on top and it's something that I set up and I probably
shouldn't put myself in a bad situation,
but a lot of times I get it.
So I like to go there.
So you mean like a crucifix where the guys behind you?
Yeah.
Like he's,
and he's,
he's on here on top of him.
Yeah.
He would know he's on his back like this.
Okay.
Right.
Um,
and then I did a back flip and I crunched myself up.
So I think I owe you punched myself.
Put yourself to sleep.
Yeah,
almost.
And he had kind of a halfway choke.
Um,
but it wasn't,
I wasn't really in a competence right here.
Oh my gosh.
Come on now.
Often Young Jamie.
Yeah.
How do you do that?
He knows what he's doing.
This was a Benson's
first fight in the UFC after Korskoff right?
Or excuse me in the bell tour.
So he fought Korskoff at 70 we're,
which is crazy.
He did not belong in that weight class.
And then to this position,
and I do this backflip,
I always end up on top.
So he's got kind of a joke and then I crunched myself.
Boom.
And then hopefully,
hopefully they'll say you,
you gone on time here and hopefully that shows my dead eyes.
Oh Wow.
That's so crazy.
Cause you look tired.
Like you were brawling.
There was,
there's another one on that you can find on the Internet that you can just look
into my eye.
The Look,
look,
look dead,
glazed over eyes.
And I looked down at my feet,
I looked down at my feet,
my feet aren't moving,
my feet were like dragging my feet.
Don't what?
What happened in this?
The fight where you lost the title,
where your leg gave out?
I stepped back,
rolled the ankle,
pinch that nerve,
and then my foot just went straight.
So from rolling the ankle,
that's what it,
that's what did it,
that's what pinch the nerve.
And you see where I stepped back and I thought like something had broken,
like a ligament had given out or something like that.
I had no idea.
I wish,
I wish I would've had the hindsight to just not chase.
I mean I have this thing where I love to hit people and run Adam and,
and like go in for the kill,
which is,
which has worked very well for me in my career.
Um,
but in that instance,
if I would just,
if I would have either number one switch to southpaw cause I could push off of
it,
I just couldn't lift it.
So I wish I would have switched to south Paul or I would have just planted
myself in the middle of the cage and waited for him to keep throwing kicks and I
would've kept kept handling.
I mean I only one punch really got landed in that entire fight and that was me
dropping him.
Now when,
when that happened,
how long did it take before your leg started working again?
Oh Man,
it was scary,
man.
I mean to two weeks later or seven days later,
I ran five miles,
so seven days,
seven days at her.
But for about three days I looked down at my foot and my brain was telling me to
lift my foot and nothing was happening at Man.
I thought it was,
it was a scary time.
I mean,
I got like you were wondering whether or not you had permanent nerve damage in
your foot.
Yeah,
and I got a great,
a great staff around me.
I mean we,
my,
my manager has hooked all of us up with Sanford medical up in Sioux Falls,
South Dakota.
I'm doctor [inaudible],
orthopedic Surgeon,
Dr Troy,
gusts,
neurosurgeon.
And when he talks about,
when they looked at it,
he just said,
you just have,
you just have pinched nervously.
Yeah.
Basically a pinched nerve whenever you did that and it just,
it,
that is crazy.
I've never seen that before.
Yeah,
it was,
it was unfortunate.
It was,
it was horrible,
you know,
but it was just one of those things.
And that was my,
you know,
I want a six,
six out of seven and that was my one loss.
So yeah,
that was our weird one too,
because it was a fight where,
you know,
it was kind of just getting going and Oh yeah.
When your foot started doing that,
I remember watching it going,
Whoa,
is his ankle broke?
Like what's going on here?
It was weird.
Yeah.
I mean in,
it's one of those things too where,
you know,
I've talked to big John about it,
I've talked to herb dean about it.
I've talked to all these guys.
I'm like,
man,
would you have stopped that fight?
And then they're both like,
man,
it looked really
bad.
You know,
it looked bad,
but,
but you're still up in your conscious is still up and conscious and I wasn't
taking damage.
I,
I could imagine like,
you know,
I mean,
um,
what's his name?
O'Malley hurt his foot and he was like,
he couldn't even walk and he was up falling down and he was about to start
getting beat up.
Like I was still on my feet.
I was still fighting.
Did it look really bad?
They look like a wounded deer out in the middle of a field,
you know,
like of course.
But you know,
I always say like if this was back in the the Viking days and you know,
you chop one of my legs off and it's me versus him to the battle of the death,
I'm still one of that fight 10 times,
10 times out of 10.
So you wish the fight kept going 100% yeah.
It's a weird way to stop a fight too.
When a guy's not taking damage,
she's just got an a leg that's not working properly.
Well,
and the problem was too,
you know,
he almost,
he basically called timeout and asked for the doctors to come in.
Once you've done that,
the fights over,
I think,
I think the ref literally thought,
you know,
he should have just called the fight,
right?
He shake,
your leg was broken or something,
like what did it,
what was his thought process,
I guess?
And then,
and then the doctors came in and then they started feeling around and they're
like,
you know,
they were like right here.
I think his Tibia is fractured.
It's,
I can feel the bone.
I'm like,
doc,
I promise you just get out of here.
Let me,
there's let me fight.
I got a crib,
I got an a calf cramp or something.
I was like,
you don't just lying to them.
I just get out of here.
Let me,
let me go.
I promise it's fine.
I don't feel a thing.
It's not hurt.
I'm good.
Um,
and then they stopped the fight and they pull the stool to pull the stool from
me too.
So remember that.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
What was that about?
That was my commissioner that was,
that was New York Athletic Commission at its best.
Like pull the stool and I fell and I,
and then a bunch of people were like,
hey man,
did they call the fight?
Because they hit,
they thought you couldn't stand.
And I said no,
I,
I hope not because that would have been very unfortunate cause I fell on
national TV.
Got Charlie Brown tie all three stooges.
Molarity currently thanks for nothing.
Dot.
Yeah.
Why did they pull a stool?
It was,
I don't know.
I see some mistake.
I think I stood,
I think I stood up.
I was like,
Hey,
maybe if I get the crowd into it,
maybe these guys will get out of here and let the fight go.
So I like stood up and I was like,
let's go,
you know,
and I was sitting on the stool and I fricking looked at him and I was like,
you better hope they don't let me off this toolbox.
I'm going to come break your face,
you know?
And then I stand up and then he,
and then the guy pulls a stool and then a second later,
I'm on my butt.
Now.
Why didn't the rematch take place?
Ah Man,
I asked for it.
And October I asked for it in November.
I asked for it in December.
And then finally I'm like,
man,
this is stupid.
I'm gonna go ahead and take a take a fight against the scariest guy in
lightweight division Yamauchi and then,
then he got injured.
Um,
so then I fought Brandon Gurts.
So it's like I've never once pulled out of a fight.
I've went into many fights,
injured.
I have never once not answered the call.
I've always stepped up and I've always been the most exciting guy in Beltour
will forever be the most exciting guy in tour.
Um,
so it's unfortunate that these things happen to me,
but it's just part of it,
man.
It's so time though to go without a rematch,
you know?
I mean to be clamoring for it.
And he hasn't defended the title,
correct?
No,
he's a part time fighter.
Part time.
What does he do full time?
I don't know.
I think he's,
uh,
it's got a job.
Kids Jujitsu,
something.
I don't know.
I don't know what he does.
I mean,
honestly,
it's,
it's baffling,
but we'll does belt or even have a heavyweight champ.
I Dunno.
That's crazy.
How the fuck do you not know?
I don't know.
Why don't you,
I mean I don't,
I don't,
you know,
it would take me a second to think about all the champs in the,
in the sport too.
They've got it stacked welterweight division.
Yeah.
Welterweight Division right now with Roy McDonald and Lima and you know,
Paul Daley and I mean Lorens Larkin.
I mean it's a fucking stack division.
That's tough.
Harsh cough.
Yeah.
That was why I was asking for the Paul daily fight.
I was trying to get that fight where you really,
I mean I just,
I want to get some big fights.
He's terrifying.
That motherfucker.
Yeah.
For about a minute and a half and then use your break as well.
Well,
his,
his grappling,
Zoe's always been his achilles heel,
but God damn that left hand is a missile that uh,
that Lauren's Larkin fight where he,
where he like knocked him out on his feet and he was just kinda like,
yeah,
there,
but not really there.
Paul Dale,
he can do that to anybody.
His left hand he has,
that to me was a crate.
That was one of the most frustrating ones when he fought Josh Koscheck.
And threw that punch afterwards and he got kicked out of the UFC basically
forever.
And now you see like Connor throwing Dolly's through windows and all this shit.
I'm like,
well,
what about Paul dailies gotta be going,
what the fuck,
man?
I got kicked out forever for this.
I even throw a punch that landed that he's like,
I wish,
I wish I was in it when it was the entertainment business.
You know,
guys like him though are very interesting where he's such a specialist,
you know,
he's such a striking specialists.
I watched him,
I watched him kickbox actually because you know Bella toward those,
those,
those kickboxing and an inmate and he and he a kickbox,
uh,
Fernando Gonzales I believe.
Um,
and it was,
it was,
oh,
he's good.
He's a really good,
especially in that kickboxing,
right,
right.
When he knows there's no take downs,
there's no threat of,
and there's a different distance there and he's really good at that kickboxing
range,
you know,
unless you're there to be able to really threatened,
threatened with the takedown.
Um,
he's going to be on his game.
One of my favorite fights of his for forever.
We'll be that fight with Nick Diaz,
which was just fucking one round of chaos,
chaos,
chaos until Nick Diaz overwhelmed them.
But nick just puts that crazy triathlon pace on you where you just can't keep up
with them.
I know.
And that doesn't give you any break.
And it,
and those guys,
those guys have both nick and Nate have done a very good job of,
of not being afraid to take some damage,
let guys like guys really swarm them and they do have that cardio.
But I think they have that.
They just have that Stockton just coughing and it's almost just like that.
I've actually,
the funny thing is like me and Michael Johnson sparred numerous times where
we're kind of like talking to each other because that's against mine.
That was against my nature like that,
that cocky braggadocious talking during a fight type of deal.
I mean once again,
that's practice of,
of almost an alter ego,
almost a little bit different.
And then my last couple of fights,
you've seen me be more present,
talking a little bit,
almost kind of egging,
egging them on,
like not being afraid it,
you should just be like business,
business,
got a fight and now it's like,
hey man,
I'm in here.
You're fighting,
you're fighting somebody who's cognitively here.
My two feet are planted firmly on this ground.
Right?
You're not bound by the moment.
I'm a hundred percent pure in the zone,
hundred percent present and in the zone,
like in the zone,
ready to die in there.
Not afraid to,
but also willing to,
willing to fight a very smart fight,
smart,
sharp,
composed,
missing shots,
taken,
taken shots or taking takedowns when I want to and need to and not being afraid
to,
to just fight like an extreme,
extremely talented veteran rather than just a vessel violence,
you know?
Yeah.
A vessel of violence as similar as the way of put it to like to think of
yourself as a professional,
doing your best to execute your skillset and such an extreme circumstance.
And how many fights have you had now?
A 22,
how many fights do you think it took before you felt that comfortable?
17 and that crazy.
Yeah,
man.
That's all.
I am not joking.
It's,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
I mean,
I wonder why I,
and now I know why so many people just,
they have a short MMA career and then they're done.
It's hard to,
it's hard.
And then,
you know,
and then,
and that's with my career going really well.
I've signed some good contracts and had and been able to do some really good
stuff and it had some big fights and had some,
you know,
had some good success.
But I can imagine these people going through the grind and then all of a sudden
you get injured or all of a sudden your manager screws you over and all of a
sudden this and that.
And I've had a really relatively not easy road.
I mean,
but,
but I've had a really good path,
but I can see how people are like,
man,
I'm done with this.
You know?
And,
and I think going back to your point to where you talk about,
um,
fighting like a veteran.
I mean I think it's all based on the confidence too.
And I see it time and time again guys,
guys,
guys only have one option and that's to fight like a crazy madman because they
don't have a hundred percent confidence in their skills.
And I think that's why you saw early in my career I fought like a mad man
because I wasn't a hundred percent confident in my skills.
I was 100% confident.
My Cardio,
my heart,
my willingness to just take damage,
my willingness to die inside the cage.
I was,
I was confident in that.
There was,
I stood,
I stood against Eddie Alvarez of 16,
18 months removed from a college wrestling room and said,
I'm going to beat that guy.
I'm not supposed to beat them on paper,
not supposed to beat him record wise.
I'm not supposed to beat him in any other,
any other universe besides right here.
In my mind I'm saying I want to beat that guy.
And I did it just by sheer toughness.
So I believe in my toughness and my cardio and my heart and all that kind of
stuff.
But I didn't a hundred percent believe in my skills.
So then all of a sudden you start to mature a little bit and you start to
realize that you have these skills,
you have these bag of these bag of tools to use and you can use them not just
effectively,
but you can use them efficiently and smart,
you know,
so you didn't under pressure under pressure.
Yeah.
And it's,
I mean,
and there's still times where you got to cut you,
you got to gut check.
You know,
and that's,
that's a good thing that I know I have in my back pocket is,
is I get in a fight with one of these guys and he's out matching me.
He's outclassing me.
He has better technique than me on that night and I'm
off.
He's,
he's technique wise,
he's not tougher than I am.
He doesn't have better cardio than I do.
He's not willing to,
to literally take as much damage I as I am and keep coming forward.
He's not willing to do that.
And that's what I've always had the confidence in,
but now I have the confidence in my skill sets as well.
When you see a guy like his,
he's one of my favorite examples,
just engaging who's just a fuck in SAP,
but you see him go undefeated in world series of fighting,
what do they call it now?
Professional Fighting League.
Is that what they call,
she'll fight league,
is that it?
Yeah,
so he goes undefeated world series of fighting.
One of the most interesting and intriguing contenders to enter into the UFC has
a spectacular debut against Michael Johnson in a fucking war.
I mean just a fucking war and then loses to Eddie Alvarez in spectacular fashion
and then loses to Dustin Poirier in spectacular fashion.
But just in those three fights has taken so much damage.
How much,
it's just crazy to watch his style when you know that he's a very good wrestler.
He's a smart guy and I mean his Trevor Whitman,
his coach,
his striking coach.
This is the same coach that coached thug rose and you look at her foot work and
move Marriner to do and technique machine.
A technique machine sliding away from things entering in,
you know,
like constantly moving,
presenting angles and different looks and Justin is just hands up high moving in
on you and just leg kicks from close distance and brawling.
And uh,
that guy can't do that very long.
Crazy that he admitted that like he hit the interview,
just came out there.
He said,
I only have five fights left in me.
I want them to be good ones.
You know,
like,
is that what he said?
Yeah.
I mean,
I could be wrong,
but I mean,
I'm pretty sure he had an interview that said I only had,
I only have five fights left.
Enemy.
And it's,
it's crazy to see that because when you're already,
and he's younger than I am.
He's like 29.
Any 28 thank you.
Something like that area.
I don't even know if he's 30 you know,
I don't think he is.
And,
and this might be a good,
didn't he start late?
Didn't he?
Didn't he wrestle in college?
I don't think he started even striking until he was 21 yeah.
So He's,
he's only been fighting for eight years,
you know,
and,
and I think,
I think it goes back to when I look at him,
uh,
you know,
it's not a knock on him or whatever.
I just don't think he has the confidence in his abilities.
I think there's a fine line between having confidence in your abilities,
confidence in your,
in your,
in your striking techniques,
your ability,
your ability to win any other way than a brawl.
Because I've had these thoughts too,
man.
I've sat and I've thought,
and the thought of me just outclassing somebody and piecing them up in the whole
world,
watching and hearing the announcer saying,
oh my God,
Michael Chandler striking is on another level.
Look at this and that and how he strings together.
His punches with his kicks in is blah,
blah.
That felt foreign.
And it felt uncomfortable to me because I didn't a hundred percent truly believe
in that stuff until recently.
And you start in and I think he has the,
he only has,
he only has the capacity to believe in himself as a brawler.
Therefore,
that's the only way he knows how to win.
Therefore in his sparring rounds,
he's not,
I bet you and I could go watch him and he's the same guy,
Justin Geechee and those sparring rounds as he is in the cage.
But is that because here's no regrets.
I have five slots left.
Like that's a tough spot.
The peon,
you know,
that's just his mentality though.
I,
I wonder if you're right about that because I think he likes that kind of
fighting.
Well that's the thing too.
I mean I think that's what he enjoys.
He likes breaking people.
Like when he broke Michael Johnson,
he just broke them.
And a man,
the fans love it.
You want some fan?
Do you want some fans?
You have a couple of those.
And I mean he's,
he's got a great following now after,
like you said,
just a couple of fights.
People believe in him.
I mean people still right now they see this like cyber war robots step into the
cage.
That's what they think.
They don't even look at him as a man.
They don't look at him as a,
he has a heart and a spirit in his brain.
They just look at a guy that who's was out.
He goes out there and he's going to just freak and trying to break somebody's
just through sheer,
not beautiful technique but just pressure and punched count and leg kicks in,
that kind of stuff.
And he's going to step into the cage.
It gets whoever he steps in the cage against,
even though he lost his last two fights and he's still going to be the favorite,
I believe.
Well I just want a liberal best leg tickers in the sport.
It's just crazy that he started striking so late.
He,
everybody gets their legs fucked up with that guy and he,
he led,
kicks the shit out of people from close range too,
which is weird.
Like literally be in the clinch and he's whipping down on your legs.
You know,
I just think he loves chaos.
I just think he loves it.
He embraces it when it,
when shit gets crazy.
That's when he's at his most comfortable and yeah.
And maybe that's me speaking from experience cause I saw,
I mean I see a lot of my s my early career very similar to that just brawl and
you know like that's,
that's what I did.
And then I,
then I decided I have these physical gifts in the speed and the power and the
ability,
the,
the mental capacity to,
to pick things up.
I mean I,
I have been blessed with very the ability to pick things up very,
very quickly and two practices.
I'm like,
holy cow,
this stuff's working.
Just after a couple of myths sessions,
you know,
Justin's shown no indication that he even enjoys doing any other kind of
fighting.
I know that's,
you use a lot of footwork and movement.
You slide and now like the tricky pitfall fight was a great example that you
slid in and drop that right hand on him.
It was a perfect closure of distance and you washed a missile on him.
He's just,
here comes bitch here.
Comms.
That's common.
And that's scary,
man.
Nobody in the lightweight division is lying when they're not a little bit
shaken.
Like,
Dang,
I got to fricking fight that dude.
Like he's that guy and the bracket,
you know,
wrestling,
wrestling there.
There's the guy who's not really ranked in our,
he's Branco seated number eight or he's not even seated,
but you know he's a goer.
You know,
he's tough.
You know he's strong,
you know he's not that good,
but he's going to be in your face for seven minutes and you could lose to him
because he's that good.
He's not the guy you want to draw first round.
If I was a biology,
I would say take some time off and really reconsider your approach because that
chaos is always going to be there.
The chaos is always going to be there.
He's always going to be able to do that.
He's always going to love that is always going to have some of the best leg
kicks in the sport.
He's a little more footwork.
That's what,
that's what I say,
the more movement.
How about some faints?
How about every now and then a little bit of this habitat her every now and then
switch up is a little bit of take downs.
How about throwing a take down,
touch your leg,
just touch it,
like make,
make,
make them think,
make fucking good wrestler.
I was in Colorado,
you know,
so,
but,
and then the other part of me says,
shut the fuck up.
Rogan,
let apply it like that.
Cause it's awesome.
I mean that's his,
that's his thing.
That's his debt.
Poor.
Yay.
Fight was fucking amazing.
And the Michael Johnson fight was fucking,
to me,
even the Eddie Alvarez fight,
it was chaos.
It was,
I'll put to the moment eddy landed that knee and Eddie's leg was in trouble.
Bad.
He was in trouble.
I thought I was waiting for it to go to go down.
I was like,
well he's got that debt boxing stance and he gets low and he puts a lot of
weight on his legs and he's got a lot of confidence in his hands.
But Donald took advantage of that and his first fight in the UFC.
And you know,
I mean just when you saw Eddie beat Hoffeld dos Santos and win the title,
what was that feeling for you knowing that you shared all those rounds with him?
Just to crazy wars.
Was that feeling like,
fuck,
that could be me.
Yeah.
I mean that was that.
I mean,
that's kind of the,
yeah,
that was,
that was when I watched it.
I was in Salt Lake City actually,
or not park city,
Utah.
I was at a wedding and so we were all just hanging out and I was like the fights
on and I was watching it,
I couldn't hear it,
but I was watching it and he was just throwing that,
that flurry and everybody who I was with was like,
holy cow,
like that,
you know,
you beat that guy twice,
you know?
And that's once,
twice
just disagree with I've,
I'm just joking.
I don't,
you know,
this is,
that's the sport and I love it.
Um,
but fought that guy twice to two very,
two very close fights and you know,
it was Kinda one of those things where it's like,
man,
yeah,
I mean,
but I knew it.
I knew,
I knew he was going to go over there and he was going to do extremely well.
I didn't know he was going to come in.
And I mean he beat,
I mean he lost it.
The loss of Donald Cerrone beat Gilbert Gilbert.
He beat Pettis.
He'd been another guy.
I believe he,
I mean he was just those two or those two.
And then you think it was just those two and then he got the title fight.
I think I might be wrong.
She does.
He would pull up his record,
but either way.
Um,
what I admire about Eddie's,
the same thing that I admire about you is that he does thrive on those wild
fights.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
he's just,
just an unbelievably tough guy.
And the gauge you fight was a perfect example of that.
I mean,
he got fucking hurt and that fight,
man,
his leg was chewed up.
Pad has his,
Whoa,
I don't know what was going on with his face.
You guys were calling it out.
We were trying to figure out what it was.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
Gilbert Pettis,
and then they'll say,
yeah,
it was,
it was just those two.
And then the loss to Donald.
But the,
the,
those two fights where,
you know,
Pettis was a champion,
at lightweight and was,
you know,
at
that time,
still thought to be in the mix,
had beaten Gilbert,
you know,
it's submitted.
Gilbert and Gilbert of course from the strike force fights mad respect for
Gilbert.
It's one of the best in the fucking world.
I mean,
it's just when you really stop and think about how fucking tightly matched that
lightweight division is and how many killers are in that division,
that is a fucking crazy division.
And in the UFC right now you got could be,
you got Tony Ferguson,
you might have Max Holloway.
I mean,
it's crazy that Max Holloway got pulled from the New York car because he was
having trouble making weight.
And he's the 145 pound champion,
which is just,
he's a tall boy,
he's a big fella to tall boy and he's a tough motherfucker.
Holy Shit.
Is he tough?
She's just got this incredible wealth of talent in this one division,
you know?
And then Kevin Lee,
how fucking good did he look against?
Barboza Holy Shit.
He did look really good.
I mean fucking Stud.
So it's,
you've got so many good fighters in this one division,
you know,
and this is why we got to bring it into the UFC.
Come was that,
why are you going to do that kind of fucking contract?
You haven't Peloton.
We've got to talk Michael Challenge about it.
32 men.
You're going to be 33 then you'll be 35 then you'll be 40 and then it'd be over.
Yeah,
I'm 50 trust me,
it happens.
It just happens.
I hope I look like you went up 50 it just comes if you will.
You won't pass any drug den.
Yeah,
they right now.
Now we got to get you in here,
man.
There's just no,
there's no other way to do it.
Well,
we're,
we're a,
we're trying to figure everything out.
No disrespect.
Beltour some cross promotion.
Some people I'll go with that be,
I would love that.
I really would.
I mean,
I think I said when Rory went over to fight in Beltour upset,
he very well might be,
here's a shout out to power off the warriors.
I don't know if that's very well.
Might be the best 170 pound fighter in the world.
It's very possible.
It's very possible he has,
I mean if he's not,
he's certainly in the mix.
Yeah,
and he might be on any given day,
I mean this is the thing like you just really don't know,
but if you look at his fight with Tyron Woodley,
I mean he essentially shut Woodley's main,
authentic down and used a brilliant strategy to beat him by decision.
You look at his fight with Maya,
he got in the worst possible position with Maya.
Maya mounted on him in the first round when they're not even that sweaty yet,
and he was able to survive that and then pick my apart.
He's one of the best in the world.
Beats Lima,
who I think is extremely underrated.
Yeah.
I think Lima is one of the very best fighters on the planet earth and it just,
people don't know because for whatever reason,
Bella toward just has not been able to capture the public's imagination the same
way the UFC.
I mean they,
I mean they've definitely grown.
I mean,
yes,
big time,
you know,
and that's,
his fight car was fucking incredible.
And it's cool.
I mean,
it's cool because I've been there for the maturation of the whole thing.
I fought,
my first fight was on ESPN Deportes days that,
that was on
that finally air to like two in the morning after like a couple of girls high
school softball game,
stop the deal,
you know,
like that was our,
our slot.
And then it moved to him,
MTV two and then spike and now paramount network and now it's simulcasts and now
on CMT and Paramont at work.
So it's cool to see the growth.
It's cool to see.
I mean,
it's growing,
you know?
Um,
and it's been,
it's been cool to be a part of the growth.
I mean I will forever probably be in the biggest fights are the most exciting
fights in Bellator history.
You know,
so it's,
yeah.
Beltour hater by any stretch to the imagination.
And I,
even though I've,
obviously I've been working for the UFC for a long time,
I'm a fan of fights and I like,
I like a high level of fights.
I don't,
I mean obviously I'm loyal to the UFC,
but I don't want Beltour to fail.
I want them to succeed.
I liked the fact that they have Rory Mcdonald.
So there is a,
there's an argument like you look at it and go,
hey these,
this might be the best 170 pound fighter in the world and he's not the of Saint.
Yeah.
Like this is all good.
I felt at the same way when fate or was fighting and pride,
I was like,
look,
that might be the best fucking heavyweight on the planet earth and he's not
here.
And I tried very hard to try to figure out a way to get him over there,
but they were super unreasonable back then.
Yeah.
Now,
the UFC faders management,
they would be crazy,
unreasonable.
They wanted cope promotion.
They wanted a 50 50 split one,
get the fuck here.
They were like,
this ain't happening man.
And then they were also saying,
look,
this guy is one loss away from losing all of his value.
You have to understand this.
Yeah.
And then when Fabrizio over doom caught him with that triangle.
Oh yeah.
The UFC was like,
we fucking told you.
We told you.
And then big foot Silva's smashed him.
And then Dan Henderson,
Kaye owed him and the EOC is like,
look,
we fucking told you you had an opportunity to bring him over here.
And that was,
you know,
it was a different time.
It was when Fado was in his prime,
you know,
it was when,
fader was smashing people and pride.
It was just a different human being than what you're seeing today at 41 but I,
I'm a fan of the best fighters in the world getting together and whatever we
have to do to facilitate that,
that's what I want to see happen.
You know what I mean?
I,
you know,
I just think that there's gotta be a way to make this happen.
There's got to be,
what are you talking about here?
You motherfucker.
Hey Man.
I mean,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm going,
going day by day,
you know,
I'm enjoying the process.
I mean,
we,
we're in talks right now.
Things are going,
things are going smoothly,
things are going,
things are moving forward.
We'll see.
Uh,
we'll see what happens.
I mean,
I know you have to say all this.
I know,
but that,
that is true.
I mean,
I want to fight the best guys in the world and no,
you don't.
There's not a day,
there isn't a day that goes by that I don't get,
I mean,
shoot,
you posted that thing this morning and there was 287 likes and 30 or comments
in,
you know,
five minutes and it was all like,
finally,
hey,
when are you going to come?
And I get that every single day.
So there's not a day that goes by that,
that it doesn't get talked about or thought about,
but especially after anyone over there and became champion.
Yeah.
Right.
And everybody knows about,
I mean,
this,
one of the things that I talked about when Eddie first came over to the UFC was
go,
I was telling people,
go watch the wars that he had with Michael Chandler.
And then I've said that also too,
when I've seen you coaching people or being in someone's corner,
I'm like,
that right there is one of the best lightweights in the planet.
Yeah.
And I just really would love to see you.
I mean,
I don't want to undercut Beltour I don't want to Dell toward,
you know,
no,
I mean it's at the end of the day,
I mean there's,
there's,
it's a competition between the two.
You know,
the two organizations,
there's guys in both organizations that are great,
like you said,
Lima and,
and all these guys and course correct off.
I mean,
there's,
you know,
in the pit bull brothers or whatever.
I mean there's,
there's some great talent in both [inaudible] and you saw it back in the day
with Strikeforce and now all of a sudden a lot of these Strikeforce guys are,
you know,
UFC champions as well.
You know,
so it's an interesting,
weird,
the way fighting is today as opposed to the way boxing.
It's like a perfect example is like,
like the Gennady Golovkin fight this weekend.
You know,
we went to see him and you know,
you go to your,
you're basically going to see one of the best boxers on the planet.
You're not going to see him because he's,
you know,
the fucking WBC guy or the Ibf guy or the Wbo God.
People don't really give a shit about that.
He's a world champion,
but the,
the war,
but it's versus Bella tour versus the UFC.
It's a big difference in the way people look at it.
Like the average public,
the people don't give a shit if you're the WBA champion in boxing or the WBC
champions,
they don't give a shit.
They just want to know who's a bad motherfucker.
Like is it,
you know,
is it Deontay wilder?
Is it Anthony Joshua who these are heavyweight champions.
Let's see him fight.
They don't look at it that way when it comes to Bella tour in the UFC.
I don't know why I have my,
my speculation is first of all,
because UFC has been around forever and it's like the NFL,
it has that name value tips.
They've done a good job of building the name value.
It's also a really good name.
Yeah,
UFC is a great name.
Bella Torah is a shitty name.
It just is.
It's just,
you know,
you go to the,
the average person like you like,
Oh,
I'm gonna Watch Bella towards tonight.
They're like,
the fuck is a ballot.
To her,
they didn't know what a Bella Torres,
but ultimate fighting championship makes sense.
Makes Sense.
And it's funny that just call it paramount MMA,
I think.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean I,
I think there,
I mean there was all kinds of new branding going on with the whole new paramount
stuff and all that kind of stuff.
I mean there if there was ever a time it would have been now,
but I mean I think they're,
they're stuck to it.
They like it.
I mean it's kind of one of them things.
They should get their money back from spike Lee and when they had to pay spike
Lee,
did they?
Yeah,
they paid them off.
because he was clearly,
he we've sued,
he sued them.
He said that you stole the name from me and they're like,
what the fuck is basically just one of those frivolous lawsuits that you have to
settle?
Like fine.
Take like one,
some keg.
This clash.
Take this money.
I want how much they gave him.
How much do you think they gave him?
Let's,
let's say,
guess how much you think they gave Spike Lee?
3.2 million.
Really?
That much?
No,
I don't know.
I made that up 1,000,050 gave him a million.
I bet they gave him a meal.
I bet you're right about it.
I'm going to go with 1.2 I'm going to,
I'm going to be in the middle.
I'm going to be the middle guy and see how much the guy,
do you think they disclosed it?
You think?
Yeah.
Did he,
did he like actually trademark spike TV?
Like someday he might actually have his own TV channel.
You his,
his thought was,
well what about Spike Jones is see like where's my fucking money?
I think he just was felt like his name was so not like the name's spike was
synonymous with him?
No.
Well it's spike was a dog,
right?
Wasn't that like it was a logo aspect of it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well cause the UFC was the ultimate fighter was on spike TV.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
2005 Stephan Bonner and Forrest Griffin now forever in debt to those guys.
They made the sport that one crazy fight.
Literally.
It was like probably one of the big pushes by undisclosed,
undisclosed,
undisclosed DePaul at me.
Spike Tom,
which got let us know,
let us know.
Spike Lee joint public statement that they settled their differences entry a
greenback.
Yeah.
A lot of people were mad at spike for that.
Spike Lee.
Yeah.
I don't remember any trip that referee.
I actually don't know if he did it.
He tripped a referee.
It wasn't the Jay z song.
Remember that one?
What are you talking about?
I had never even saw it.
I spike Lee tripped a referee.
He said being in the NBA,
a lot of Knicks games.
Yeah,
so trip the referees supposedly.
Well that's what Jay z said.
He said,
I'm spiked out,
I could trip a referee and I'm like,
oh trip a spike.
Lee must have tripped to referee one time because he has always courtside at the
Knicks.
Is that supposedly,
is there video of this?
I think he's saying it because he sits court side.
I don't think it actually one of those things.
One of those things,
one of those I could trip a rapper could trip a referee.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird?
Like basketball?
Like you can get like right up to the ash so close.
You could literally get,
you could trip a referee.
Yeah.
Whereas like you know football,
you're pretty fucked back.
20 feet,
50 feet.
I mean,
I've talked to about this so many times people get angry at me,
but what would you think about the idea of fighting in a big open area without a
cage?
Like a big open area?
Like a basketball ring?
Yeah,
I mean a basketball arena.
Like a basketball court,
like that size.
If you had like wrestling has where you have boundary lines.
Yeah.
Could you actually go out of those boundary lines and they'll stop the bash,
stop the action.
I'd have to bring you back in.
It didn't have to be some reason.
It would be like a college.
It'd be like the coliseum.
Exactly.
So big that you're almost,
there almost are no barriers.
Well yeah,
because I think that there's something about a cage that presents an artificial
boundary and that artificial boundary can be used both to contain someone and to
get out to get up.
Like you could obviously wall walk and get up out.
I just think it makes take downs much more difficult when there's not a cage
because you know you're not going to press someone against cage,
just scooped their legs out from under him.
You have to get a legitimate takedown.
Yeah.
Like an open area takedown.
And it makes getting up much more difficult when you're,
when someone does take you down,
smashing up against the gauge,
you can't just scoot your backup to the wall and get back up.
You're
going to have to figure out a way to actually get up now.
Yeah.
Well that was one of the things too.
I mean,
going back to become,
you know,
being a wrestler,
I mean your wrestlers coming in should not just expect that they're going to be
able to take guys down and not get taken down.
I used to get taken down all the time off the gate and I'm like,
man,
I'm a division one wrestler.
Why am I getting taken down?
But it's,
it is completely different.
I mean obviously I know a lot about maneuvering the body and,
and,
and you know,
scrambling out and all that kind of stuff.
But adding the cage wall is a lot different,
you know,
when you first started training,
um,
did you immediately start training in a cage?
Uh,
I think at extreme get tour,
yeah.
There was,
there was a cage so we would,
we would spar in a cage.
Um,
but now I don't,
I don't really spar engage anymore.
You don't?
Not really.
How come?
I don't know.
I mean down in,
down in Florida we don't have one and we just spar in the open.
There's,
there's cage walls.
Well there's cage walls that like if you're in training camp,
you know,
if you've got a fight coming up soon,
uh,
you'll spar in this certain area where they might put some,
some Thai pads on the floor,
like don't go past this.
And then there's your other barrier type of deal.
Right.
My Gym,
we don't have a cage,
we just have a cage wall and then a padded wall too.
So the cage wall just so to work on wall walks and things like that,
you get chewed up on those fucking things too.
That's why,
that's why I just,
I like to use the padded wall,
you know?
And I mean,
the only difference is there's a little bit of a give a little bit of,
if we give you the cage wall,
there's not on the pattern wall,
but man,
yeah,
if you're not wearing gloves and elbow,
I mean I've busted a bursa sac and my elbow before or it and it just takes a
week to heal,
you know?
Or you look at you and you look at your back in the mirror and it's just,
it looks like a bunch of hickeys all over your back,
your head.
You can get ripped apart.
You're evil,
there's cut open,
you know,
like I'm actually down,
gotten cut open like nick,
tell just a little bitty one on my,
from the fight.
Yeah.
By just hitting the cage because it's metal,
you know,
it's not,
yeah.
It's one of those things that I think is a legacy idea.
I just don't,
it's hard to see too,
when you're in the audience and you're looking at it like there's often,
and those pillars get in the way.
He cool.
It'd be cool if there was just,
just a,
a single caves.
They didn't have to be bolted together.
Therefore there was no,
there was no,
no posts posts.
But then again,
you know,
you'd have to have a top post,
right?
You have to have a top post and a bottom post,
and then the,
the cage would have to be so rigid that it held everything together.
You know,
how the fuck would you do that?
It would be almost impossible because it's,
or maybe it's if you lower the men or maybe it's too,
yeah,
exactly.
Just the guys just stand there and then they just get locked in and then big.
Yeah,
there's no doors.
Spartans just like lock this thing down and yeah,
there's like elevators that was like the,
the,
the big UFC back in the day.
W what was it got our Davey.
Yeah.
When they started talking about the,
all the ideas where they were talking about putting a moat around the cage and
sharks and alligators and like,
we're really gonna do this thing big.
Everyone's going to love it.
That's our Davies,
the same guy that brought us a x arm wrestling or whatever the fuck it was.
Oh yeah.
The armor,
you know when it is the tied your arms together and the beat the shit out of
each other.
Really like the Michael Jackson
bad video MMA arm wrestling event.
Oh it was actually a moment where you literally tied the guy's arm together.
So you are in the RMS and the situation.
You sit down,
beach taped your arms together and then you were punching each other and kicking
each other in bars.
Yeah.
With the arm wrestling podium in front of you.
Here it is.
Oh my gosh.
I have no idea how you find these things.
So cause we made fun of this like a week ago.
It was so fucking stupid.
They taped their arms together and these guys,
first of all,
don't ever throw that kick.
Yeah.
Um,
but look at,
this guy's got an arm bar.
Oh my goodness.
I mean,
which is crazy cause your arm can get fucking snapped.
I mean you have a table that you're doing as Armbar over you.
You don't even have time to tap and they can't separate you.
Once you do tap,
look at this.
Oh No,
look at how crazy that is.
They're stopping the fight,
but even though they stopped the fight,
paint his arm and his arm cause you can win by getting an arm like or knock him
out.
It was so stupid.
This is one of the dumbest ideas that humans have ever come up.
Oh man,
look at this.
That dude,
but it's entertaining.
I would watch it.
I guess I would watch it horrible.
I'm watching it right now,
so I'm talking shit.
I would watch it,
watch it 100% but the arms are taped together,
which is just crazy.
I love how they,
the ref comes out and does the tape job too while everyone's watching and you're
like,
oh,
that guy's out cold hanging off and it's awesome.
Then you're connected to them.
You should just like run and start dragging him around the danger.
It was such a dumb idea,
but see it what?
What was that like?
Was that online?
Was that paper view?
Was that,
how was that?
I don't know.
It's one of those things that just,
it was just,
it just existed for awhile.
It happened for a second.
Yeah,
it happened for a little bit knocked out and they're like,
okay,
is there a commission?
Do you have to have a commission?
They probably did that on some fucking island somewhere.
Exactly right.
Sounds good to national waters on a boat or something like that.
No idea how they got away with that thing.
It's just so stupid.
But that was our debut,
Huh?
Yeah.
I believe,
didn't he just get a inducted to the hall of fame?
Yes I did.
Yes he did.
Rather um,
wasn't there a frank shamrock had a good idea where they were doing one in like
a,
it was like a pit.
Okay.
Sort of a thing.
Which would be cool cause you couldn't really climb out.
Yeah.
I know they have something similar to that.
Now with this a karate thing that boss ruin is involved with Florida.
Yes.
Luke.
Uh,
Luke Rockhold is,
has gone to a couple of live events I think.
Yeah.
They're doing that now.
We would take like real high level karate guys and they were MMA gloves and
yeah,
I think there are ladders.
Yeah.
Padded,
like kind of walls type of deal.
Yeah,
well it's like a slanted area where you know,
you know,
you hit the barrier and it's weird like you could punch a little bit on the
ground.
It's very strange.
Like boss had it in.
You're allowed to punch on the ground for five seconds.
Like you take a guy down and you could punch him in the graphs for five just
stand up.
Yeah.
Which is like,
oh,
okay.
It's like we had a little beat is facing.
Come on man.
Well it's like that.
This idea needs a little bit of work.
It's a little bit of show you think it's going to make it or you think they got
the bus route and thing.
I mean,
hopefully I look,
I think more,
the more stuff we can have the better,
but I just think they need to iron out the rules.
Like I love glory.
I love kickboxing.
I love lion fight when it was on,
but I think now it's only online or something like that.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's hard to find good high level Moitai good high level striking.
That's not just boxing,
you know,
this,
it's really hard to find.
Well that's,
yeah,
exactly.
Well and that's why you've seen all these organizations come and go are these
kind of crazy ideas?
Nothing is sticking.
Yeah.
And a lot of instances,
but it's,
so that's why it's cool to see the growth of MMA,
you know?
And that's why it's,
it's a cool time to be a part of this.
You know,
this generation of in May as an MMA grows and,
and like you talked about asking about myself.
I mean you see in all kinds of guys having success with karate style and,
and like kind of on your toes,
bouncing kickboxing style,
shoot point,
kickboxing style.
Um,
and you're seeing a lot of people come in cause it's cool.
It's flashy.
The fans love it.
The promoters love it.
Michael Page.
Exactly.
You know,
I mean he's a perfect example of a guy who was a real high level point karate
fighter who's now the real Tufts puzzled to solve in MMA.
Yeah.
Who was he fighting next?
He's fighting one 70 right?
Fighting one 70 I don't think he has a [inaudible] word.
I don't think he has a,
an MMA fight schedule.
He,
I know he had a fight in October,
but that was,
he had a boxing match.
Yeah.
I was,
I knew one by chaos once ago.
A long time ago.
May,
and I know they were trying to set up a fight with him and Paul did layer,
which would be fucking chaos.
Yeah,
but Paul Daley was just saying something.
I read an article,
I just read the headline,
said Bella toward thinks I'm a fool and I ain't one,
so I don't know.
Daily.
Yeah.
Paul Paul Daley was not very happy for a second.
That's why I was very interested or I was surprised to see him.
Who did he just,
he just signed to find a [inaudible].
Who was he fighting?
I don't know because this was the,
I read this.
He's fine.
Line one in London,
I believe it was yesterday.
See if he was find out into it says Paul Daley.
Oh,
John Fish.
That's right.
He's coming back to FAU or John Fitch is coming back.
That's terrible.
Fight for him though.
John Fitch is all rustler.
Have they fought yet ready to fight John Fitch?
I don't think I know.
I don't believe they did.
Coming off impressive.
Second round knockout a fair federal.
Yeah.
Fellow UFC veteran.
Lauren's Larkin.
So He's been,
he's been out for a while too.
Cause that fight with little wrens.
I want to say it was six months ago plus right?
That was on my card and September.
September.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I mean he,
I know he came out,
he wasn't very happy about some stuff.
So that was eight months since his last fight.
So is that what he's upset about?
That he hasn't gotten a fight in a long time?
I mean,
I think it's,
it's like you said,
belt or thinks I'm a fool,
blah,
blah.
Then he's,
he said,
he basically said he was walking.
There you go.
Yeah,
Belle Belle tours playing me for an idiot and I ain't an idiot,
idiot,
idiot.
When you say that one idiot,
his British accent even better.
But that's uh,
that's interesting.
I ain't happy with what you guys are finally a fight.
That makes sense.
Hold on at,
scroll back up.
What is he saying?
Um,
Beltour wanted him to fight John Fitch belt to one nine,
nine to Saturday.
One thing went through his mind.
I thought finally a fight.
That makes sense.
Daley said in case you couldn't tell.
Um,
I've had great times of belter.
Okay.
Is it just they just,
um,
they just take it a quote out of context and making it the title,
which they always do,
right?
They play me for Nydia and ain't it just be done with all the bullshit?
Let me fight.
I love how they bull expletive just right.
Oh Shit.
You fucking pussies.
Let me fight.
Let me go.
Or you treat me like you want me to be here.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
well that's a good fight though.
The John Fitch fight the good fight because striking wise obviously has,
he has a giant advantage,
but Fitch has been around a long time.
He knows his shit and he's a fucking brutal wrestler and this is a fix his first
fight in Beltour.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just came over from profile league.
Yeah,
it was last.
Yeah.
Well,
there was it,
what they're calling it world series back then.
Yeah.
And Fitch fought Paul Horez and that was when Paul Harvey has got disqualified.
Right.
Lose the heel hook and he held on to,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was bad for a couple of fights in a row.
[inaudible] we'll do that man Harris.
I love when people call him Paul Harris like Paula,
who's Paul Harris and well I didn't know he was good and I'm like,
okay.
Yeah,
he holds on to shit.
bad but refs like ripping a wall.
Yeah.
Well which is actually awesome.
It's Kinda crazy.
Terrible.
It's your knee.
Yeah,
it's terrible if it's your knee,
but it's like awesome for fans.
But then the fans are like,
half of them were ticked off having more pumped up like glocks.
Now you know,
you're really seen them in MMA.
You're seeing them a shit load of them in Jujitsu,
professional submission matches.
You're seeing the leg lock game because of like the Donna,
her death squad and a lot of those guys just seeing it dominate competition.
I almost got my leg ripped off like a lot of things.
It'd be a lot different if I would've not,
if I would've tapped in in that fight,
that first fight against Marcy unhealed first round,
he's known more tournament,
phenomenal Jihad.
He had it so deep man and like sprained my hamstring a little bit,
like pulled it,
popped it and then I had to fight three or four weeks later again.
Wow.
But man,
almost almost written any of that.
Do you train a lot of leg lock submissions?
Do train defense?
Like not a lot.
You know what to do in a situation like that.
I mean I think there's a couple,
you know,
there's a,
there's a couple like um,
basics,
you know,
if you get,
if you get into,
he'll hook roll with it or if you get caught in a knee bar,
pop the legs open,
the open.
Um,
but do you work with like high level leg lock eyes now to really understand the
whole chain of events that happens?
No,
not,
I mean,
it's hard to find good leg lock guys.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's almost like throwing elbows and knees and practice a guys.
Guys don't throw them or practice them as much because it's,
it's hard
to practice them without putting people in really bad danger.
You know,
you were asking,
you accidentally hit someone with an elbow cause you were simulating it.
You catch an eyebrow and it's over.
Right?
They've got 12 stitches.
Same thing with leg locks.
I mean people will get it.
I actually got caught in a leg lock by Mario Sperry,
this last training camp.
Now that I think about it,
Mario Sperry's still rolling.
Still Rolling man.
He's like,
you Gella come here.
And how old is z now?
Mario gotta be 15 he's the man,
man.
He's,
he's awesome.
Really,
really nice guy.
I deal veteran man.
A real pioneer.
Jujitsu and MMA.
Yeah,
we were,
it was a wrestling day.
It was a wrestling day and we went to the ground and we just kept going.
I had wrestling shoes on.
He caught me in it.
I was like,
what can I give the old tap real quick?
Cause I'm like,
man,
you get wrestling with wrestling shoes on.
It is no joke.
You Ain't getting out and nothing.
So it's like,
Yep.
Got me.
Yeah.
Thanks coach.
Let's go again.
Yeah.
The whole leg lock game has evolved.
It's scary men cause that's especially like he'll,
I'm not a heel hook,
but when they take the,
the ankle,
like just like bend it.
Right.
We know what it's calling Dennis did this week.
So that's what happened to me.
There you go.
I got caught in a knee bar,
got out of the knee bar and then he switched to the toehold.
Felt my ankle pop,
pop,
pop.
And then just what,
um,
what inspired you to talk a bunch of shit about Dylan Dennis after his
disappointments?
I don't know.
I don't think he looked very good.
I think if you don't think it's Jujitsu look good.
Oh he knows.
All right.
I mean he,
he was,
he,
you know,
he went there and I sold transition,
grabbed,
grabbed the leg.
But I mean he looked like a fish out of water on the feet of which of course he,
he shoots again a fine when they fight.
But I think it's,
I mean,
do I respect what the wind,
do I respect what he's done.
And Him and baby Bjj.
That's cool.
But it's not mixed martial arts and it's just,
it's funny how much he's getting called out for being literally just,
uh,
you know,
I want to be Connor with all the same thing saying the exactly the same exact
style.
He realizes how good it gets you paid.
Exactly.
You know,
he's,
he's doing a good job with it,
but he also said he's,
he's the highest paid fighter in Beltour.
I mean,
just all kinds of like silly stuff,
you know,
it's just like,
dude,
is that what he said?
No.
So he's chill son in a little bit.
He's a dark man.
Just huge door.
Okay,
so you just like one of those things where it's like,
well,
when the guy's making his debut and you are a world champion or a former world
champion at this point,
what,
what inspires you to call a guy like that out?
Just because I mean it,
doesn't it help him?
Yeah,
I guess.
I guess it does,
but it also,
I mean I also woke up to 150 mentions on Twitter.
So it's like well at least people are talking,
you know,
at least people that,
people are talking.
I mean that's the other thing too is,
is always navigating the,
the narrative and talking about getting people to talk.
Yeah.
Getting people to talk about,
I mean over the last couple of months,
the amount of times like our students could be before the amount of people that
were just talking like,
hey,
you're the only guy that can match Khabib's wrestling.
You're the only guy that could notify as wrestling.
I mean to get yourself in the conversation.
That's what it all is.
It's all well style's definitely make fights.
And that was what,
what became very interesting,
uh,
after the outlier Quinta fight where people were looking at,
okay,
what about high level wrestlers who have more refined
striking.
Yeah.
And how do they line up?
And Kevin Lee was a big one that people kept talking about.
But you are a big one that people kept talking about too.
Yeah.
Cause you were saying that you think you could beat him 100% and him having that
fight with,
I acquaint to who he was a prohibitive favorite over,
but it went the full five rounds.
And you know,
I Quinta,
although never wanna round showed some chinks in the armor.
So shakes in the armor showed,
it showed what happens when Khabib can't take you down.
I mean it's,
it's tough whenever the one thing that you've always been used to dominating
with isn't working and then you're stuck.
You're stuck throwing punches and you're,
you're,
and you know,
you know,
he,
he just,
he's a,
he's a little bit behind in the striking aspect.
Dude,
I've got a ton of respect for the guy.
Mauler I mean,
at certain times he looks unbeatable.
He has looked unbeatable where I've looked at it and other people have looked at
it and people that have fought him,
that have talked that I've talked to Barboza fight.
He just fucking mauled Barboza and it's,
and it's just a,
it's a battle of wills,
man.
You're inside of a cage and it's just like we talked about,
I knew I could outpace people.
I knew I could out out cardio.
Then I cut out tough them,
you know,
certain people get to that breaking point and they break and they can see it and
they go into their shell and they say,
I did a good job,
but this one's on him.
This is guys who don't have that deep,
deep wrestling background.
And they face a guy who does.
There's moments in the fight where you see that where you saw that thousand yard
stare and Barboza his eyes were,
he was like,
fuck,
like I can't keep doing this.
Like he's,
he goes into defensive survival mode.
Yeah.
And you know when a guy does have a deep background in wrestling and also can
strike,
that's what makes it interesting.
And this is why MMA is such a complex sport because there's so many variables.
There's so many techniques you can use.
There's so many situations where you might have an advantage or your opponent
might have an advantage.
And it's just,
we live for these matchups,
these stylistic matchups.
So when something like that happens and a guy like could be B has a fight where
all these questions get presented,
that's where a guy like Michael Chandler comes into the mix.
Yeah.
Well,
and I love like after that fight to,
uh,
cause I said something,
I posted a video.
Do you see the video?
Me scrambling with Kamara crazy.
Yeah.
That was awesome.
And I said,
if,
if a,
if all he has his wrestling,
how do you beat a man?
Can't be taken down,
you know?
And,
and I got so many messages from,
you know,
Russian guys that had just said it could be,
it could beep time,
you know,
of course,
and it's like,
um,
yeah,
I mean it's,
uh,
it's one of those things,
man,
where I mean,
that,
that fight with Eddie.
I mean,
the fight with could be,
it's a,
it's exciting.
Kumara who smart.
It's gotta be going fucking crazy right now,
seeing Colby Covington getting a shot,
the interim title,
he's like,
you mother fuckers.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
He's,
he wants to fight that dude.
No,
I have no,
I wouldn't,
I mean that dude is,
I mean he is,
he's a specimen.
He's got wrestling.
He's got striking.
I mean you,
you watch him spar,
you watch them hit mid
or you watch his composure and his confidence while he's sparring and do all
that kind of stuff.
You'd think he's been striking since he was 11 years old.
You know,
he just started after,
after college,
you know.
Well he had his good,
tough fight with uh,
with um,
meek mill.
Yeah.
Email Mika or whatever,
Emil Meek.
Um,
but I think that a meal meek is extremely underrated.
Extremely under.
I mean,
he's a fucking tough guy.
Very physically strong.
Very,
very strong.
I was,
I was even email make a couple of times.
I was like trying to mimic him,
but where are you in training camps?
But yeah,
we are at the same time and he's,
and he's done that.
Him and I train a ton together and it works out well for me because he's a
bigger guy.
I like to go with a little bit bigger guys so I can just continue to get
stronger and manipulate bodies that are bigger than mine,
you know?
Yeah.
And a lot of people were criticizing him for not being able to finish meek,
but I'm like,
you're,
you're crazy.
Yeah.
That is a fucking animal.
It's,
it's,
it's nuts.
The amount of people you know,
armchair quarterbacks that are,
that are literally out there think saying,
you should've finished this guy when you're all professional,
like professional fighters training day in and day out.
It's not easy to finish a guy sometimes.
We'll see how I was saying.
You got to stay the fuck away from,
you wouldn't mention,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's like,
man,
it just blows it.
Oh my goodness.
Especially for a guy like you,
if you do have something like an ankle injury like that,
that one fight and then you got to stay offline for a few weeks for sure.
I mean,
I still get it to this day.
Well,
how are you training?
Are you working on your rubber ankles?
Are couple other fuckers.
They know your soft spot is man.
I looked at my uncle said,
man that is a well enabled ankle and ready to kick somebody in the head with it.
So you didn't suffer any ill effects of it once it,
the nerves came back.
Now once I came back,
I mean I've,
I've done a lot of rehabbing and I think,
I think my legs or my,
my feet in general have,
it's something that I've continued to work on.
I mean you got to look at each,
each individual joint from hands,
wrists,
elbows and knees to ankles.
I mean,
and all of my strength and conditioning work,
a lot of it is very,
very hard.
Very,
very tough,
very,
very violent.
And then some of some of my stuff is stability stuff,
core stability stuff,
hip flexibility,
hip,
hip strengthening stuff because that's where the all your power and all that
kinds of stuff in a yoga at all.
Um,
I do yoga.
I,
I've done,
I've done hot yoga in the past and we just opened up my gym in Nashville has a
900 square foot yoga studio that actually opened up this morning at six at him.
Oh,
so they go what a great yeah.
So I'm gonna show up and just show up and uh,
work on that core stability.
And is that a hot yoga place or regular yoga?
Regular Yoga temperature to keep the room.
Um,
it'll be right around that 80.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I mean people,
we had that hot shit.
Yeah we had training the other day and we had about 12 people in there were
shooting some content and had some training and,
and we had to bring towels back there because people were coming out and they're
like,
hey,
you got any towels?
Cause if people were sweating our butts off,
so,
and I think we're going to get some cool infrared panels to hang on the ceiling.
That could kind of add the add a little bit of heat to where it's not hot yoga,
but it's definitely warm enough when you're going through your flows,
your,
you're definitely opening up the muscles in your opening,
you know,
getting that sweat out.
So,
um,
so how often
do you work on your flexibility?
Do you work on stretching and I bro,
I'm on my roller every day,
so I mean,
I believe in Roller Roller Lacrosse ball.
I just found this really cool cross balls or awesome cross ball.
Yeah.
Have you used those?
Uh,
do we have one in here,
Jamie?
No,
those uh,
mobility wads from rogue.
I need,
I need to call those the blue.
But was he called it star something star?
Uh,
uh,
fuck.
Does he call it?
I thought it was a wad.
The Blue Ones?
Yeah.
Well why does it work out of the day?
Super.
Nova Supernova.
Yeah.
Wad supernova.
That's what he kept flat at the bottom and the,
no,
it's all right.
We got one out there.
I'll show it to you after the thing.
But it's about the site about a little bit bigger than a softball,
but it's got all these little knobs on it.
It's hard.
It's track.
Here it is right there.
I love that God damn thing built over 2.0 that seems like the smaller one,
right is two of them.
He has a Kelly Start and yeah,
there you go.
You have a small one or a large one I whatever.
For whatever reason I think I prefer the larger one.
My,
my soft tissue guy down in Florida has one of those things that you show me
again.
Did I shut this thing called a so right look up to,
so right.
PSL that P.
I love you know what to sell as is.
Yes.
Here.
I mean that's always been one of my big,
one of my big things.
You literally lay on that thing and if you know what it feels like to get your
your,
so as worked on,
you just kind of wobbled and wiggle until it hits it and then you can lift your
legs.
This guy does all kinds of videos where he's hitting.
And so as he hits the,
he gets the glutes,
he hits the quads,
he hits the literally everything.
And he's got the,
so as many southern plane on that,
the last couple of months,
um,
David Goggins was saying that his,
the tightness in his psoas muscles was like crippling is running.
It's d.
It's,
it's literally the,
in my,
uh,
like you ever see people with the wrestler back where their butts out and it
takes you a second to stand up.
That's all.
So as pulling everything down,
being bent over or throwing,
throwing kicks,
I mean,
for whatever reason,
I've had horrible,
horrible problems with my,
so as,
and every single kind of chink in my armor has gone back to the PSOAS muscles.
The so as which is connected to the,
to the spine,
down to the ILIAC crest,
I believe.
And then there's something called the Elio.
So as where the Iliacus and the PSOAS are connected,
that Jamie,
this is a peck thing that he do,
it does what it too.
So it's not just the,
so as muscle squeezes it to loosen up your packs and man,
it's,
it's incredible how much that relieves.
Like sometimes I get like some hip tightness,
tightness,
and I'll,
uh,
get that supernova out and I'll roll on that fucker.
I know over my hips and my know or else it just,
he pounds every single day and gets worse and worse and worse.
And,
and,
and also too,
just lengthening everything.
Yup.
Your,
your diaphragm.
All of that just continues to get crunched and crunched and crunched and you
can't breathe.
You know,
look at him.
He's having a good time over there and he's,
it's a wall.
He's got a,
he,
I mean,
he only had his whole body with,
he actually has the exact
same thing in a mini.
It's like literally like only three inches long and heal.
This is a feels underscore PSO,
underscore good lol.
That's on Instagram.
Yeah.
Um,
so what is your diet like?
Diet man embraced the monotony.
That's what,
that's what my hazmat and chicken and Broccoli,
I got a mega fit meals.
Um,
and that's,
and that's what I,
I make my own meals throughout all training camp.
When it's chicken and Broccoli,
or it's beef and Broccoli,
or it's chick peas,
Broccoli.
I love Broccoli.
I mean,
I don't love,
I don't love Broccoli.
Actually.
I do love it Broccoli.
But I love the fact that a couple of weeks after I look in the mirror and say,
Dang man,
I'm getting down.
Fans are starting to pop out.
I mean,
that's,
and that's one of the biggest problems with people's fitness journeys.
They focus on the weight on the scale.
Are they focused or not seeing the results that they want to see?
But you just got to,
the problem is the w the,
the work that you put in this week and next week,
you're not going to see for two or three weeks.
You know,
that,
that delayed gratification.
But I mean,
I get my meals,
it's six ounces of chicken,
a cup of Broccoli,
um,
two or three times a day,
or I go beef and Broccoli.
Or now do you supplement it as essential fatty acids are?
Yeah,
I take,
I take flaxseed oil or uh,
I take fish oil officials,
it shows in the morning.
Um,
and then,
yeah,
I mean I,
I mean when it comes to supplementation,
I do protein and Aminos every single day.
That's been,
that's been my biggest thing.
I mean,
did you branch chains Aminos after exercise?
Diamond ties and is 50 50 blend?
They have the,
it's like a two one,
one two,
two of the losing two of the Leucine,
one of the veiling,
one of the ISO,
leucine.
How long did you take that right after training?
Um,
I usually drink one blender bottle,
one serving of it as I'm going into practice.
And then I'll have another one going into the next practice and I'll have a
protein shake after.
Maybe that's what you're throwing up.
No,
I don't throw up.
I don't,
I tried to get myself to throw up,
but I don't.
Um,
and I drink the diamond ties.
I still have 100 protein,
which is like,
it's the big,
it's,
it's the cleanest and like almost lightest protein.
Know a lot is based on what is it a whey protein,
but it's a weight whey protein isolate.
Okay.
So something in the way it breaks down or you know,
[inaudible] know exactly all the,
all the specifics of it.
But I mean,
when it comes to bodybuilding,
a lot of those bodybuilders use that because of the fact that it's isolated.
Right.
So,
um,
and what about multivitamins,
things along those lines?
I mean,
I,
we,
we go,
uh,
I do like an athletic nutrients,
which is basically just like a,
an extended version of a multivitamin.
I have this daily detox one that I take that has a fish oils and a little bit of
Taurine,
a little bit of other stuff in it.
Um,
multivitamin,
um,
tumeric,
honestly,
I mean with,
with grey amount of inflammation,
I have tried to do a lot of tumeric throughout the,
throughout training camps.
If I do,
I try to stay away from the leaves and the Tylenols and that kind of stuff.
Unless I'm,
that's great in pain,
you know,
I want to try to get tumeric and drinking juices and that kind of stuff.
Tumeric,
ginger shots,
Cayenne pepper.
Did you do that every day?
I try to.
Yeah,
try to.
It's one of those things where it's like everyday but everyday loosely.
And I was like,
that sounds phenomenal.
I did this morning.
Yeah.
And uh,
what about,
um,
do you do cryo or did get massages or sauna or anything like that?
I do.
I do soft.
I tried to do a soft tissue massage or sports massage,
um,
kind of rolfing art almost every week.
I mean,
like I was saying,
I'm on my roller every single day before practice and that's,
that's when I really see,
you know,
like these,
these times after a fight when I'm not working out as much or I'm not,
you know,
not everything is on because you can't be on all the time.
You know,
everybody acts like they're on three 65 and 365 days a year,
but they're really not,
you know,
after a fight,
I kind of go less robot mode,
you know,
break my diet a little bit,
enjoy staying up late and joy and just doing whatever.
And then that's when I really realized,
holy cow,
I've been on my roller in four days and that's why my back is hunched over and
stuff.
So you just get too busy and you just don't know what the time.
Yeah.
Give it in there.
So I'm hitting my roller and then I like to get a massage every single week.
Um,
chiropractic often.
So yeah,
I saw something on Russian wrestlers where they were getting massage every day
after training and I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I do the roller everyday.
So I mean,
I imagine some sort of soft tissue work could be very,
I mean,
man,
we'd beat the crap out of our bodies,
you know,
nothing like it anywhere.
I mean,
other than football,
I guess.
I mean,
in terms of the amount of abuse your body takes,
the cons,
I mean,
you're,
you're basically in a sport where your desire is to break someone's body.
Yeah.
And,
and just the,
the little things,
man,
I was sparring with Nick lense two training camps ago and I threw it,
I threw a leg kick as he lifted his,
his opposite leg up and literally just dead leg to me.
Like Charley Horse,
me with his knee.
It wasn't even supposed to happen.
He didn't mean to do it.
I didn't,
I was trying to throw the leg kick and I got the worst deep muscle,
like bone contusion in the middle of my,
like where,
where your quads meat right between the muscles.
And I could not walk.
I fell right to the ground.
Practice was over,
you know,
this was like three weeks before the fight and I had to go see my,
my guy see Kay in Florida.
He just had to work the heck out of it,
man.
And that's,
I think that's one of the biggest things.
Um,
and I just talked to one of the guys at Marc pro about when we talk about
injuries,
we used to think rice,
you know,
rest,
uh Aye.
Aye.
Compression elevation and that kind of stuff is,
there's some conflicting kind of knowledge on all that kind of stuff.
Whereas instead of resting it,
get in there right away and start moving it,
moving it and mobilizing it with certain things.
Obviously got a broken leg and you need to get it set and get it,
get arrested.
But do you do cryotherapy at all?
I don't.
I mean,
I saw that a couple of times.
I've done it.
I've done that a couple of times.
I haven't done ice baths really.
I mean,
a lot of times it's just,
you almost got to pick and choose.
There's only so many hours in the day too,
you know?
So it's like,
you know,
you're waking up and you got,
you got only so much time before he go to practice and then,
then you only have so much time to recover before the next practice.
And it's,
and it's one of those things where I'm always getting a massage.
I'm always working on,
you know,
maybe I'm doing massage and chiropractic during one camp and you know,
it's,
it's almost like you got to pick and choose your battles.
If you know,
if you have an awesome man warehouse like this where everything's in one spot,
I would do it all every day.
But if you're down in Florida and this is [inaudible] 45 minutes away and your
massage is 20 minutes the other direction and you're fighting Florida traffic,
you really got to pick and choose your,
your recovery methods.
You know,
right now your gym in Nashville,
this is your gym and I was following you on social media where you're putting up
pictures,
you putting everything together.
How satisfying is that been is awesome man.
I think,
I think the satisfying now that it's open,
I mean obviously there's a lot of work that goes and tell people how they could
find out about it.
Where you go.
We are training Camp nashville.com and follow us on Instagram at training Camp
Nashville.
Now that we're open.
I mean my,
my big thing is,
you know,
I'm very active on social media.
We want to,
we want to start doing a ton of video as a ton of,
um,
kind of cool,
same,
similar workouts that like I do,
and pump out a bunch of information out there.
I mean,
my,
my biggest thing is I wouldn't be where I am today without surrounding myself
with great people,
great coaches,
and be important too.
And I just wanted to,
I had this vision 17 years ago and I was like,
I told my dad,
I said,
dad,
I want to open up a gym.
And he said,
well,
if you're gonna open up a gym,
I'm going to build it with my bare hands.
And my dad now just finished my gym with his bare hands,
so,
you know,
that's fucking cool.
So he,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
every,
every screw,
every nail in that place was,
was put in by my father.
So it's,
it's cool.
And it was,
and it was when I was a,
you know,
15 years old or whatever.
Um,
very similar to my wife's vision of,
of adopting a child.
And like that came to fruition same exact year.
So it's like just these angels.
Yeah,
a lot of changes,
you know,
but I mean it's,
it's cool.
I wanted four walls and a roof where people can walk in and say,
you know,
they're,
they're looking for a change or they're looking to to eat.
Whether it's get stronger,
get faster,
get you know,
lose that weight that they finally won had been putting off.
You know,
I wanted a place where people can say because of that guy or those people or
that coach,
I was able to enrich my life.
I was able to become a better person.
I was able to increase my self confidence or you know,
just so do you have actual life classes for like just general fitness classes
for martial arts,
beginner's classes?
Do you have like the full range and then also professional?
Yeah,
so I mean we have a lot of,
a lot of stuff going on.
I,
I've almost been fighting a decade now.
I've been started out in Missouri,
went to the west coast,
now I'm turning it on the east coast and I've been to Canada.
I've been to numerous training camps in between.
And the gym is called training camp.
And the reason is because my life has always revolves around training camp,
you know,
and there's a difference between like we just talked about in training camp and
out of training camp.
Um,
how'd you settle on Nashville and my wife and I just loved the city.
We're both fucking great city,
isn't it?
Great City.
Yeah,
we're both from A,
we're both from Missouri so it's closer to home where we grew.
Um,
we were living in San Diego together and wanting to just move back closer to the
Midwest.
We'd love the city.
You have a bunch of friends in the music industry so we,
you know,
had some friends there already and visited and went to a couple of award shows
and said,
man,
this place is cool.
And it was just there a couple of weeks ago,
four or five weeks ago,
whenever it was.
I love it there.
It's a cool space.
It's an amazing city.
It really is.
From,
from top to bottom to Ama.
We,
I mean,
we met so many people and you know,
you kind of pride and ask questions and they just said,
man,
it's a great place to raise a family.
It's a great,
great school systems,
great.
You know,
the weather's is better than Missouri,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
you get all four seasons,
it's a great place to raise a family.
And that's kind of what we knew we were about to start a family.
So we wanted to wanting to do that and uh,
love the city and now,
and I saw an untapped him MMA market there too,
you know,
I mean,
there was,
there was a couple of MMA gyms there,
but there was no,
there was no legitimate pro fighters that were there.
I mean,
Luke Sanders is from there in the UFC.
He went out to California.
Uh,
Dustin Ortiz was there.
Both of those guys were born and raised there.
They both went other places.
I said,
you know what,
I want to go to Nashville and I'm going to make it the premier place.
Or my gym is going to be the premiere place to to do mixed martial arts training
in Nashville.
And we're going to put Nashville on the,
on the map.
Now you're going to have wrestling classes,
kickboxing classes though,
the whole all of it.
So we have,
we have,
so back to that,
we have a lot of stuff going on.
We have 3000 square foot of just fitness area where it's rolled rubber flooring,
um,
turf plate loaded machine squat racks,
dumbbells group fitness area.
Right next to that we have 3000 square foot of mat space where we're going to
have a youth wrestling club would that has four kind of for a half wall around
it.
We started youth wrestling club this week coupled with another 1500 or 3000
square foot of Matt's 1500 they're 1500 of of the Fuji Tatami Mats for boxing,
kickboxing,
Bjj,
and they may,
all that kind of stuff.
And then that 900 square foot yoga studio.
Plus we have our recovery recovery area that we have a guy named Scott Dunaway
at Kairos strengths.
He's a chiropractor,
art and corrective exercise guy.
Plus we're trying to bring in another massage therapist that's going to be there
three days a week.
And then I'm also going to talk to a Cryo guy as well who has uh,
an extra tank that I'm going to try to set something up with.
I think it does.
So then when everything's under one roof then,
then when we were like,
Hey Joe,
I've been doing cryo man,
cause it wasn't 45 minutes away,
you know?
Yeah.
What,
that is the thing,
right?
It's time management.
When you're in your training,
how many times a day and when you're in camp twice usually,
you know,
but then there's always,
there's always something to,
you know,
and then there's the media station media obligations or,
I mean just even,
even with your nutrition stuff,
it's like,
oh man,
got to go,
got to go get,
got to go make a whole foods around to get my almond milk and my Avocados.
Because I make my own breakfast,
but the rest of my stuff is in a mega fit meals,
uh,
containers,
you know?
Um,
so there's always a grocery store to go to or there's always a media obligation
and there's always something and it's all time management.
You know,
I always,
it was always interesting when I heard some people like,
yeah,
train 10 hours a day.
And I'm like,
really?
How do you train 10 hours a day without your body falling apart?
You know?
Yeah.
People exaggerate a little bright.
And I'm like,
for sure.
I tried two hours in the morning balls to the wall and I trained two hours in
day and at night balls
to the wall and I'm like,
okay,
pass out,
wake up,
do it all over again.
Groundhog's day,
embrace them and not eat chicken,
broccoli,
eggs,
avocado.
Let's do it for eight weeks.
Make wait.
Well listen,
Michael,
I'm glad we finally got a chance to get together and have this conversation and
let people know what you're all about,
man.
And I'm a big fan and I really appreciate you coming in here.
And,
uh,
I hope one day I can commentate one of your fights.
It won't be in belt or,
so.
Yeah.
That,
that will be great.
Well,
thank you.
I appreciate,
I really,
really appreciate it.
Absolutely.
Thank you,
Michael Chandler.
Ladies and gentlemen.